GOOD MORNING. WE ARE GOING TO
CALL THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU CALL
THE ROLL.
TING HERE.
OBERNOLTE.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BLUE.
CARILLO.
CHAVIS.
CHIU.
CHOI HERE.
COOPER.
FOR.
GARCIA.
HARPER JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
LOW MOAN.
MATHIS.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MOHAN.
MOORE SUCI.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
RUBIO.
STONE.
VOEPEL WHETHER.
WOULD YOU.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET ME JUST.
FIRST START OFF BY. THANKING
THIS COST OF FOR BEING HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
I DID WANT TO NOTE AND WAS WAS
VERY PLEASED TO SEE. THAT
SIMILAR TO OUR ASSEMBLY BUDGET
BLUEPRINT. THAT THE GOVERNOR
DID.
FULLY FUND THE RAINY DAY FUND
AS WELL AS ADD ADDITIONAL MONEY
FOR RESERVES.
HE ALSO PROPOSED TO FULLY FUND
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA.
HE ALSO ARE PRESENTED NEW
FUNDING FOR KRIER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION SPECIAL EDUCATION. AS
WELL IT'S EXPANDING THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDITS
THAT WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO SEE
THE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
THERE. ARE FOR INCREASED CORE
OPERATIONS IN THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO STABILIZE AND EXPAND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE'S ACTIVITIES.
ON THIS COSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN STERN
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS I'M I'VE
PREPARED A BRIEF POWER POINT
PRESENTATION THAT I'D LIKE TO
PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE. OF
WITH.
JUST REALLY THE HIGH LEVEL IN
MAJOR COMPONENTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET.
BEFORE YOU START ABOUT THIS
BUDGET I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO LOOK BACK IN THE PAST
ON WITH CUTS MAJOR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS SINCE TWENTY
ELEVEN.
AT THAT TIME WE ELIMINATED A
TWENTY SIX BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
PROBLEM AND A TWENTY BILLION
DOLLAR ANNUAL SHORTFALL.
AND THE BUDGET HAS BEEN BALANCED
AND WE'VE ENACTED ON TIME HOW
FOR SEVEN STRAIGHT YEARS.
SO.
BY ANY MEASURE ARE PROPOSED
BUDGET IS A GOOD BUDGET ON
ESPECIALLY COMPARED TO OUR
PREVIOUS AYE BUDGET
DIFFICULTIES.
WE ARE PROJECTING A ONE TIME
SURPLUS OF SIX POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS WHICH INCLUDES ROUGHLY
FOUR POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN INCREASED REVENUES OUT SINCE
THE BUDGET ACT PROJECTIONS.
WE PROPOSE AT MEETING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL TARGET OF THE
RAINY DAY FUND IS THE CHAIR
MENTIONS.
AND ALSO WITH INCREASED REVENUE.
WERE DRIVING ON SOME HIGHER
EXPENDITURES IN THE POP NINETY
EIGHT SIDE OF THE EQUATION ANA
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES
PROPOSE I THREE BILLION IN LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA DOLLARS
AS THE CHAIR OF THE TO TO. ARE
BRINGING IT TO FULLY FUNDED TWO
YEARS EARLIER THAN WE HAD
PREVIOUSLY PROJECTED.
WE ALSO PROPOSED THE CREATION
OF A NEW ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE I'LL GIVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL ABOUT THAT LATER IN
REFERENCED WE ARE PROPOSING THAT
CALIFORNIA COMPETE PROGRAM FOR A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS. ANNUALLY OVER FIVE
YEARS AND AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS AS SPECIFICALLY
FOR SMALL BUSINESS ASSISTANCE.
ADDITIONALLY WERE PROPOSING
RECONFIGURING I'M ARE HIRING TAX
CREDITS.
AT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
I'M SPECIFICALLY TARGETED TO
THOSE WITH BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT.
LASTLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
PROPOSES.
FOUR POINT SIX BILLION IN
ADDITION TO THE CURRENT YEAR
FUNDING IN SB ONE FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS.
BRINGING.
TOTAL FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO SEVEN
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
HOWEVER WE STILL HAVE A MANY
UNCERTAINTIES ON THE HORIZON.
WE ARE STILL AND AS OF OUR
BUDGET.
PUBLICATION INTERNAL DEADLINES
WE WERE NOT ABLE TO INCORPORATE
A THE FEDERAL I TAX REFORM
PROVISIONS THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR DOT THROUGHOUT MAY
REVISE.
ON HOWEVER I THINK LARGELY AT
SOME OF THE IMPLICATIONS OF THE
FEDERAL TAX REFORM WILL REMAIN
UNKNOWN TO US.
ON WE CERTAINLY KNOW THAT IT
WILL IMPACT INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
BEHAVIOR TO WHAT DEGREE LARGELY
UNKNOWN AS PEOPLE FILE UNTIL
TWENTY NINETEEN. ADDITIONAL
THERE WILL BE SOME LARGER
ECONOMIC IMPACTS.
WE'VE FRANKLY MAY NOT KNOW A
WITHIN THE TIMEFRAME OF THIS
BUDGET THOSE MAYBE MORE LONG
TERM IMPLICATIONS.
I WE DID GET GOOD NEWS
YESTERDAY.
WITCHES THAT CHIP WAS
REAUTHORIZED AND SO WE WILL
ADJUST.
IN THE MAY REVISE OBVIOUSLY DOT.
REIMBURSEMENT RATE WOULD HAVE
HAD MAJOR IMPACTS ON OUR BUDGET
SO THAT WAS A BIT OF GOOD NEWS
COMING OUT OF DC YESTERDAY.
WE WILL STILL BE MONITORING
THOUGH.
ANY BUDGET.
HUH.
ANY OF THE FEDERAL BUDGET.
DEVELOPMENTS.
I THINK ONE OF OUR CONCERNS IS
THAT AT THE TALK ABOUT FEDERAL
BELT TIGHTENING.
FREQUENTLY THAT TRANSLATES INTO
A CAUTIOUS TO STATES SO WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THAT
PROCESS.
AND LASTLY OF THE GOVERNOR NOTED
DURING THE PRESS CONFERENCE AND
AS WE'VE NOTED IN SEVERAL OF OUR
PUBLICATIONS. A WERE ALWAYS
COGNIZANT OF THE NEXT RECESSION
AND SELL PART OF OUR OVERALL
ARCHITECTURE WAS TO REALLY BUILD
A ROBUST RESERVE. A IN
ANTICIPATION OF THAT NEXT
RECESSION.
LASTLY OBVIOUSLY WE'VE HAD A
SERIES OF NATURAL DISASTERS IN
THE STATE. ON INCLUDING MUD
SLIDES WILDFIRES IMPORTANT NOT
OUR THING AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SO YOU'LL SEE
THAT IN ADDITION TO THE RAINY
DAY FUND WE'VE INCLUDED A
HEALTHY DEPOSIT IN THE STATE
FUND FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY TO
HELP US PAY FOR SOME OF THOSE.
UNANTICIPATED EMERGENCY RIPOFF
RESPONSE COSTS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THROUGHOUT THE BUDGET FORECASTS
WE STILL ARE SEEMING ECONOMIC
GROWTH HOWEVER WE WOULD CAUTION
THAT IT WOULD ACTUALLY MARK. ON
IT WOULD MATCH THE LONGEST
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN STATE
HISTORY POST WORLD WAR TWO WE
WOULD BE ON PAR WITH THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN NINETEEN
NINETY ONE. A WHICH IS AGAIN
WHY%
WE'RE STILL CAUTIOUS ABOUT AT
THE POTENTIAL OF A RECESSION OR
AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
WE DID INCLUDE A AYE RECESSION
SCENARIO IN OUR.
BUDGET DOCUMENTATION I BELIEVE
THE ANALYST IT AS WELL. AND IN
OUR RECESSION SCENARIO WE WOULD
BE LOOKING AT.
A DIP OF TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR A TOTAL OF
SEVENTY BILLION DOLLARS ACROSS
THREE FISCAL YEARS.
AS NOTED WE ARE PROPOSING
FILLING UP AT THE CONSTITUTIONAL
TARGET OF TEN PERCENT OF
REVENUES IN THE RAINY DAY FUND.
UP ON THE NATURAL UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF PROPOSITION TWO
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
WOULD BE REQUIRED WERE PROPOSING
A SUPPLEMENTAL DEPOSIT OF THREE
POINT FIVE BILLION WHICH WOULD
BRING OUT THE TOTAL FINE. TO THE
THIRTEEN POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR FIGURE YOU SEE THERE.
ADDITIONALLY WE PROPOSE TWO
POINT THREE BILLION IN THE LAST
DAY FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY AND AS I SAID
PREVIOUSLY THAT STILL WITH
WILDFIRES NATURAL DISASTERS AND
OTHER UNANTICIPATED COSTS THAT
WE MAY ENCOUNTER.
AND ALTHOUGH PROP TWO HOUSE
LARGELY HELPED US REDUCE SOME OF
OUR DEBTS ON IN IN RECENT
HISTORY WE HAVE TACKLED SOME OF
OUR UNFUNDED LIABILITIES.
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO REDUCE
THE WALL DEBT FROM THIRTY FIVE
BILLION TO LASSEN SIX BILLION.
ADDITIONAL WE HAVE PLANS TO PAY
DOWN.
ALL OF THE MAJOR STATE
RETIREMENT RELATED LIABILITIES.
UP WE STILL DO HAVE SOME OF
THESE COSTS AND SO AGAIN OUR
ARCHITECTURE IS TO KEEP AND
ABOUT THE ONGOING EXPENDITURES
VERY LIMITED TO GIVE US
FLEXIBILITY TO DEAL WITH SOME OF
THESE ONGOING HOW LIABILITIES.
I HEAR YOU SEE HISTORIC CHART OF
OR PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING AND
YOU CAN SEE SENSE I TWENTY
ELEVEN BUT I GUARANTEE HAS
INCREASED BY SIXTY SIX PERCENT.
OUR CAREER PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE IS UP BY SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION. AND THE.
PROPOSED AMOUNT IN BUDGET YEAR
IS SEVENTY EIGHT POINT THREE
THAT WOULD BRING OUR PER PUPIL
SPENDING TO ELEVEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN DOLLARS.
AS NOTED WE ARE PROPOSING FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA TWO YEARS
EARLIER. ADDITION WE HAVE A
PROPOSAL FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS
FOR CT  PROGRAMS WE WOULD
ACTUALLY CONDUCT THE K. TWELVE
SIDE OF A CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. IS BUILDING UPON A
REASON INVESTMENTS IN THE STRONG
WORKFORCE PROGRAM WHICH IS BASED
ON THE FEDERAL WORKFORCE
INNOVATION.
AND OPPORTUNITY ACT FUNDING OR
WE YALLA. IT'S A REGIONAL
APPROACH IN WHICH I REGIONAL
CONSORTIUM DECIDES WHAT THOUGH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT NEEDS
AREN'T ANY COMMUNITY AND THEY
WORK ACROSS SEGMENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT TRAINING IS AVAILABLE.
TO MEET THOSE REGIONAL NEEDS.
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE A SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROPOSAL WHICH WOULD
INCLUDE A HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO BUILD
CAPACITY FOR CHILDREN AGES ZERO
TO FIVE.
AS WELL AS ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS I HAD TO EXPAND TEACHER
WORKFORCE THROUGH RECRUITMENT
AND TRAINING SPECIFICALLY FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHERS.
LASTLY WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
PROPOSALS THAT WOULD IMPROVE
SPECIAL EDUCATION TRANSPARENCY
BY ALIGNING THE SUPPLE PLANS
WITH THE LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLANS TO MAKE SURE THAT. ON
THOSE PLANS ARE INFORMING ONE
ANOTHER AND AND BEING RELEASED
AT THE SAME TIME.
IN CHILD CARE WE HAVE A ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR A AND
AUGMENTATIONS IN THE CHILDCARE
PROGRAM SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN.
THIS REPRESENTS THE FINAL YEAR
OF AN AGREEMENT WE REACHED FOR
THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN ON CHILD CARE FUNDING.
I HAD THE STATE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE WOULD INCREASE.
BY TWO POINT EIGHT PERCENT FOR
TOTAL FORTY EIGHT MILLION. AND
OTHER PERMANENT REGIONAL MARKET
RATE WOULD BE HELD HARMLESS.
WE HAVE SOME PRETTY MAJOR
PROPOSALS AXING THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE A ARENA.
THE FIRST IS THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING A NEW ALLOCATION
METHODOLOGY FOR OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES RIGHT NOW WE USE
ENROLLMENT BASED FUNDING TO FUND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WE'RE
PROPOSING A SHIFT TO AN
ALLOCATION FORMULA. WHICH WE
BELIEVE WOULD PROVIDE MORE
STABILITY FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ON THAT EMPLOYMENT FUNDING
REALLY DOESN'T ENROLLMENT
FUNDING IS OFTEN REALLY TIED TO
THE ECONOMIC CYCLE HOA AND
OVERALL UNEMPLOYMENT RATES.
SOARING NEW ALLOCATION AND.
WE PROPOSED A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO HOLD
DISTRICTS HARMLESS ON AND MOVING
TO THIS NEW ALLOCATION METHOD.
IN THE NEW ALLOCATION METHOD
WOULD BE BASED FIFTY PERCENT ON
ENROLLMENTS TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
ON THE NUMBER OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS THAT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SERVES AND WE WOULD
DETERMINE THAT DOT THROUGH OUR
PROGRAM RECIPIENTS AS WELL AS
THOSE RECEIVING THE BARBER THE
PROMISE WAIVER.
AND THEN THE LAST PORTION OF THE
FORMULA BE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF DEGREES
OR SEARCH OF
COMPLETED WITHIN A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
WERE ALSO PROPOSING A I HAD THE
CREATION OF OUR ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ON THAT WOULD BE BASED
AT THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
WE'RE PROPOSING A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING TWENTY MILLION OF WHICH
WOULD BE ONGOING HIGH IT WOULD
REQUIRE P. SIGNIFICANT UP FRONT
INVESTMENT ON TECHNOLOGY AND TO
BUILD OUT THE CURRICULUM.
WE ARE AIMING THIS PROPOSAL AT
THE TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WERE WORKING AGE.
BETWEEN TWENTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE
WHO DO NOT HAVE A COLLEGE DEGREE
THEY HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
THEY MAY HAVE SOME CREDITS.
BUT THEY HAVE NOT ACTUALLY
OBTAINED A A COLLEGE DEGREE OR
CERTIFICATE AND SO WERE
SPECIFICALLY TAILORING IT TO
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO KNOW
DURING THE LAST RECESSION THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT DIDN'T HAVE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. WERE IMPACTED
DISPROPORTIONATELY IN A JOBLESS
RATE AND DURING THE RECOVERY
WERE AYE THEY'VE RECOVERED AT A
MUCH SLOWER RATE THAN THOSE WITH
A HIGHER EDUCATION DEGREE.
LASTLY I WE DO PROPOSE HAVE
PROVIDING FORTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT
THE AB NINETEEN PROMISE PROGRAM
THAT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW. LAST
YEAR.
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WE
ARE PROPOSING A HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS FOR A HOME
VISITATION PILOT.
THE PILOT WOULD RUN THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO THE A
DOLLAR AMOUNT IS ACTUALLY ACROSS
THOSE THREE YEARS TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT THE PILOTS. AND IT
WOULD BE TO SUPPORT YOUNG FIRST
TIME PARENTS.
ADDITIONALLY WE FULLY FUND THE
TO YOUR SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
AGREED TO AS PART OF LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET AND PROP FIFTY SIX THIS
INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS TO
CONTINUE THE SECOND YEAR. AND AN
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE.
I WOULDN'T KNOW THAT IN THIS
PROGRAM.
BECAUSE OF THE A CRUEL NATURE
WE ARE GOING INTO THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR SO ORIGINALLY
CONCEIVED THE SUPPLEMENTAL RATES
WE HEADED ACROSS TWO FISCAL
YEARS WERE ACTUALLY EXTENDING
INTO THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR WE CAN
TALK ABOUT ABOUT THAT A LITTLE
BIT LATER IF YOU HAVE.
IT'S ABOUT THAT.
LASTLY WE ARE PROPOSING AN
INCOMPETENT INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL DIVERSION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE OVER A HUNDRED
AND FORTY INDIVIDUALS. ON THE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL WAIT
LIST.
AND SO WE'RE PROPOSING A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR LOCAL
DIVERSION EFFORTS TO HELP THESE
INDIVIDUALS WITH AN ADDITIONAL
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
SPECIFICALLY FOR LOS ANGELES FOR
THIS PURPOSE.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THEY
MENTIONED EARLIER OBVIOUSLY
WE'VE DEALT WITH SOME
SIGNIFICANT NATURAL DISASTERS IN
LAST COUPLE MONTHS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE PROPOSE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROPERTY TAX
BACK FILL FOR THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES IMPACTED BY
THE WILDFIRE. AGAIN WITH OUR
INTERNAL PUBLICATION DEADLINE WE
DID NOT HAVE THE NUMBERS FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WILD FIRES
OR MUDSLIDES BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THOSE
COMMUNITIES AS WE HEAD TOWARDS
THE MAY REVISION. WE JUST IT
DIDN'T ALLIED WITH OUR
PUBLICATION DEADLINE.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE PROPOSING
EXTENDING THE COUNTY ASSESSOR
PILOT PROGRAM FOR FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. AND LASTLY WE HAVE
A PROPOSAL THAT WOULD PROVIDE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A FIFTY PERCENT
LOCAL HOT MATCH GRANT PROGRAM TO
REPLACE ELECTIONS EQUIPMENT. AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AS I MENTIONED WE ARE EXTENDING
THE CAL COMPETES PROGRAM TAX
CREDIT FOR A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR FIVE MORE
YEARS.
WE DO OWE YOU ADDITIONAL DETAIL
ON OUR SMALL BUSINESS PROPOSAL
FOR TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
DIRECT ASSISTANCE ARE.
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT ANALYST IS
RAISED ABOUT THIS PROGRAM AS WE
HAVE LOOKED AT THIS PROPOSAL.
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE
RECONSTITUTING OUR STATE WHAT
HIRING TAX CREATED A FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT PARTICULAR
PROGRAM WAS NOT UTILIZED THAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE CREATED AND THE
WAY IN WHICH PEOPLE ACTUALLY
UTILIZE IT SO WERE WERE WORKING
ON THAT PROPOSAL TO MAKE IT MORE
EFFECTIVE.
AS I MENTIONED I SB ONE FUNDING
BETWEEN THE CURRENT THE BUDGET
YOUR TOTAL SEVEN POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS.
ADDITION WE HAVE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD RESTART COURT CONSTRUCTION
WE WOULD PROVIDE THIRTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE MEDIA
AND CRITICAL NEEDS ACCOUNT. AND
WE WOULD PROVIDE LEASE REVENUE
BONDS FOR TEN COURTHOUSES.
WE ALSO HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
OF WHICH SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD BE FOR ROOF REPAIRS TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD BE FOR
MOLD REMEDIATION. AND THE
REMAINDER WOULD BE FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY RADIOS AND SPECIFIED
VEHICLES.
LASTLY WE HAVE INCLUDED A
PROPOSAL WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
APPROPRIATIONS FOR BOTH THE
UPCOMING NATURAL RESOURCES BOND
AND HOUSING BOND. IF THOSE BONDS
ARE NOT PASSED BY VOTERS THOSE
APPROPRIATIONS WOULDN'T GO OUT
ON A IT WAS A WAY TO BETTER
ALIGN THE TIMING OF IT SINCE.
SINCE THE BALLOT DOESN'T
NATURALLY ALIGNED WITH OUR
BUDGET SO THAT IF THEY WERE.
ENACTED BY VOTERS THE MONEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO GO OUT SHORTLY
THEREAFTER.
AS WE SAID OUR PUBLICATION THE
CAPITAL EXPENDITURE PLAN IS NOT
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IT WILL BE RELEASED IN CONCERT
WITH THE GOVERNOR STATED THE
STATE LATER THIS WEEK.
WE WOULDN'T OUT THERE'S ONE
POINT TWO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
OF AID OF AVAILABLE FOR
EXPENDITURE FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FOUND THAT
REPRESENTS THE FORTY PERCENT ALL
AVAILABLE FOR EXPENDITURE NOT
THE CONTINUES APPROPRIATIONS
SIDE AT THAT GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND.
ADDITIONALLY WE PROPOSE FIFTY
POINT SIX MILLION ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
OF THAT AMOUNT SIX POINT SIX
MILLION AS GENERAL FUND.
EIGHTEEN MILLION IS FROM THE
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT AND TWENTY
SIX MILLION WOULD BE FROM THE
TIRE RECYCLING MANAGEMENT FUND.
THESE FUNDS SERVITUDE FULL
PURPOSE IT WILL MAKE THE FUND
ACTUALLY SOLVE IT WE HAD SOME
ISSUES WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
AND IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW THEM TO
EXPAND SOME OF THEIR EFFORTS
INCLUDING IN AREAS SUCH AS
CONSERVATION APPROVING HUNTING
AND FISHING CONNECTING MORE
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE OUTDOORS.
AN INCREASING STABILITY AND
SERVICES FOR THE PUBLIC
INCLUDING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LASTLY DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION RECEIVES ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ALSO UNDER SB ONE THE
BUDGET INCLUDES AN INITIAL
INVESTMENT OF FIFTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS OF THESE FUNDS. OF WHICH
FORTY TWO MILLION WOULD BE
SPECIFICALLY FOR INCREASING
SERVICES ACROSS A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS EMPHASIZING THOSE THAT
DIRECTLY BENEFIT PARK PATRONS.
LASTLY OUR NOTE OF CAUTION THEY
OFTEN USE THIS CHART AND IT'S
JUST A REMINDER THAT THE
HISTORIC TOWARD TREND IS THAT
FREQUENTLY IN CALIFORNIA ARE
BALANCED BUDGETS. HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWED BY HUGE DEFICITS YOU
SEE THE RED LINES WHICH
REPRESENT THE DEFICITS FAR
OUTNUMBER THE BALLOTS BUDGETS
ABOVE THE LINE. AND THAT'S
REALLY A KEY COMPONENT OF THE
ARCHITECTURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET IS A ROBUST
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACT AND AS
AFTER YOU TO HELP US WHETHER.
THESE HARD TIMES AND I WOULD
KNOW IN OUR RECESSION SCENARIO
EVEN AT THIRTEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION WHICH IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING TO A PLOT IN THE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACT. OR
MODERATE RECESSION IS THAT
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS SO EVEN
THEN THERE WOULD BE SOME
DIFFICULT DECISIONS THAT WOULD
NEED TO BE MADE SHOULD WE FACE A
RECESSION. WITH THAT AND HAPPY.
RICHARD ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU I THINK WILL WILL.
YEAH I THINK WE'RE GONNA DO IS
ON HAVE MAC GOING THE WILL TAKE
QUESTIONS.
MR THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD MORNING.
ON JANUARY TWELFTH MY OFFICE
PUT OUT OUR OVERVIEW OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS WE DO EVERY
YEAR TO PROVIDE SOME INITIAL
COMMENTS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO DO
IS JUST VERY BRIEFLY PROVIDE
SOME HIGHER LEVEL COMMENTS ABOUT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
AND LET ME START WITH HIS
OVERALL BUDGET STRUCTURE. UP I
THINK YOU CAN SEE IN BY MS
COSTAS COMMENTS THE GOVERNOR'S
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE ECONOMY TURNS
SOUTH NEXT AND I THINK THAT'S
THAT'S APPROPRIATE. IT CERTAINLY
HAS DRIVEN IS BUDGETARY
DECISIONS.
BY OUR ACCOUNT IF YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT SORT OF DISCRETIONARY
MONIES THAT THEY HAD AVAILABLE
TO THEM.
THE GOVERNOR PUTS ABOUT FOUR
FIFTHS OF THAT ARE OVER FOUR
FIFTHS OF THAT INTO RESERVES.
THAT LEAVES VERY LITTLE LEFT
OVER FOR EITHER ONE TIME
SPENDING OR ONGOING SPENT.
NOW THAT'S A VERY CAUTIOUS
APPROACH.
IT'S THE MOST CAUTIOUS THING YOU
CAN DO BECAUSE NOT ONLY ARE YOU
NOT SPENDING THEM YOU'RE NOT
COMMITTING TO A HIGHER BASELINE
THAT YOU MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO
AFFORD.
WHEN REVENUES HEAD SOUTH.
BUT IT ALSO IS MONEY THAT GOES
INTO YOUR RESERVE IT'S A CUSHION
THAT HELPS BY YOU TIME.
TO DEAL WITH ANY DOWNTURN THAT
DOES COM.
THE GOVERNOR DOES HAVE SOME ONE
TIME SPENDING PRIMARILY ON
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHICH WE THINK ARE BROUGH SOME
VERY GOOD PROPOSALS.
A THAT'S THE NEXT MOST CAUTIOUS
THING THAT YOU CAN DO WHILE YOU
ARE SPENDING THE MONEY THEY'RE
NOT AVAILABLE TO GO ON YOUR
RESERVE YOU'RE NOT COMMITTING
THEM TO ON ON GOING. A SPENDING.
ANY HAS A VERY FEW ONGOING.
I COMMITMENTS
NOW CLEARLY E. YOUR MAKE
DIFFERENT CHOICES.
THAT THE CHAIRMANSHIP HIS CLAIM
THAT HE PUT OUT IN DECEMBER I
THINK IT FOLLOWS BASICALLY THAT
SAME OVERALL STRUCTURE THOUGH.
THINK ABOUT YOUR RESERVES HOW
MUCH YOU WHEN IT'S BEEN FOR
ONGOING SUCH AS DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE. WHAT YOU HAVE
LEFT OVER FROM ONGOING
COMMITMENTS SO IT'S IT'S A GOOD
WAY TO THINK OVERALL ABOUT THE
BUDGET AND THE TRADE OFFS OF
DOING? EACH OF THOSE THREE
DIFFERENT THINGS.
I WOULD SAY THAT THESE ARE VERY
GOOD TIMES BUDGETARY ONLY
SPEAKING.
TAKE A MOMENT TO ENJOY THEM.
.
THAT DOESN'TMEAN THAT YOU
SHOULD PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE AS
I THINK THIS CASA STRESSED AND
IN.
HER COMMENTS.
NOT ONLY DO YOU WANT TO PREPARE
THAT RESERVE YOU WANT TO GET
READY PAY OFF DEBTS GET READY
FOR THAT NEXT DOWNTURN.
BUT YOU DO HAVE OTHER CHALLENGES
FACING YOU.
WHETHER IT'S
POSSIBLE ACTION AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL ON HEALTH CARE THAT YOU
MIGHT WANNA RESPOND TO
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT YOU
HAVE.
WILL A TALK FOR A MINUTE ABOUT
PROP FIFTY FIVE AND DECISIONS
THAT COULD AFFECT YOUR FUTURE
COMMITMENTS.
SO YOU DO HAVE STILL LOTS A
CHALLENGES PENSIONS I'M SURE ALL
OF YOU ARE HEARING FROM YOUR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS FROM
YOUR.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABOUT CAL
STIRS CALPERS RATES WHAT IT'S
DOING TO THEM SO THERE'S STILL
LOTS OF CHALLENGES OUT THERE BUT
OUT IF THIS IS A GOOD BUDGET
YEAR.
LET ME TURN REVENUES.
AT AS MISS COSTA MENTIONED THEY
HAD PUT THEIR BUDGET TOGETHER
BEFORE THE EVEN KNEW WHAT WAS
THE FINAL ACTION ON.
THE FEDERAL TAX LAW.
AND EVEN IF YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENED TO FINANCIAL
MARKETS SINCE THE TIME THAT THEY
SORT OF PUT THEIR BUDGET TO BAD.
I THINK THE SNP'S PROBABLY RISEN
ANOTHER TEN PERCENT. SO BOTH
FINANCING MY OFFICER SORT OF
CONSTANT TRYING TO CATCH UP WITH
WITH NEW DEVELOPMENTS IN WITH
NEW.
ECONOMIC DATA.
BUT JUST TO A FOR SOME
PROSPECTIVE IF YOU GO BACK TO
OUR NOVEMBER OUTLOOK THAT WE
PRESENTED JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO.
OUR REVENUES FOR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
BUDGET WINDOW.
ARE THREE POINT FOUR BILLION
HIGHER THAN FINANCES
JANUARY BUDGET NUMBERS.
AND TO BE CANDID WITH YOU IF WE
WERE REDOING THOSE NUMBERS TODAY
THEY WOULD PROBABLY BE HIGHER.
NOW THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT WE
RIGHT FINANCES WRONG I THINK
WHAT IT DOES SUGGEST THOUGH IS
YOU DO YOU HAVE.
QUITE A BIT OF UPSIDE ON THE
REVENUE NUMBERS WHEN YOU GET TO
MAY.
AND YOU HAVE TO WAIT TILL MAY.
PEPSI WHAT HAPPENS WITH APRIL
AND. TO SEE JUST WHERE WE ARE I
THINK BOTH OF US WOULD AGREE TO
THAT.
BUT GIVEN THAT THERE ISI THINK
A LOT OF UPSIDE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR YOUR PLANNING
PURPOSES.
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT WHAT HAPPENS
IF YOU HAVE MORE MONEY.
AND THE REASON ANOTHER REASON I
RAISE THIS IS BECAUSE THIS
SITUATION WE HAVE NOW IS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT YOU. FACED
IN THE PAST.
WHEN YOU HAD EXTRA MONEY.
USUALLY A GOOD CHUNK OF THAT HAS
TO BE SPENT ON PROP NINETY
EIGHT.
THE CONSTITUTION REQUIRES.
AS MUCH AS HALF A NOTS MUCH HAVE
AT LEAST HAVE TYPICALLY BEEN
SOME YEARS WE REPENT ALMOST
EVERY ADDITIONAL DOLLAR IN NEW
REVENUES.
FOR SOME PORTION OF THAT NEW
MONEY TOWARDS NINETY EIGHT.
THAT IS NOT THE SITUATION THIS
YEAR.
YOU DO NOT HAVE WHAT'S CALLED
MAINTENANCE FACTOR YOU DON'T
HAVE TO DO THIS.
CATCH UP THAT YOU'VE HAD TO DO
IN THE PAST.
SO IF YOU DO HAVE EXTRA MONEY.
ALMOST ALL OF IT IS IN EFFECT
FREE FOR YES YOU DON'T HAVE TO
MAKE ADDITIONAL COMMITMENTS.
TO NINETY EIGHT.
IN ADDITION PROP TOO WHICH
REQUIRES OUR PAYMENTS INTO THE
RESERVE AND TO PAY OFF DEBTS.
THAT ALSO CAN TAKE A BIG.
PIECE OF ANY NEW DOLLAR.
ESPECIALLY IF THOSE NEW DOLLARS
ARE RELATED TO CAPITAL GAINS
THAT'S JUST THE WAY THE PROP TWO
FORMULA WORKS.
GIVEN THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL TO FULLY FUND THE
RESERVE.
THAT TOO IS NOT A FACTOR RIGHT
NOW.
SO I THINK THE POINT I WANT YOU
TO WALK AWAY FROM IS IF YOU DO
HAVE MORE MONEY WHEN YOU GET TO
MAY.
IT'S ALMOST ALL DISCRETIONARY
MONEY YOU CAN DO WHATEVER YOU
WANT WITH IT.
YOU CAN SPEND MORE ON SCHOOLS IF
YOU WANTED YOU COULD PUT IT MORE
RESERVES. AT INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT
HEALTH ONIONS WHATEVER YOU WANT
YOU YOU'RE NOT AS RESTRICTIVE AS
YOU WOULD HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST.
WHEN REVENUES INCREASE BETWEEN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND THE
MAY REVISION.
I THINK THAT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT DIFFERENCE FOR YOU SO
JUST TAKE THAT INCOME WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU MIGHT DO.
WITH EVEN ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
IF WE GOT TO MAY.
LET ME TALK FOR A SECOND OUR
RESERVES. BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO BUT THREE AND A HALF
BILLION AN OPTIONAL PAYMENT INTO
THE BSA. IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
PART OF THEIR PLAN AND OBVIOUSLY
WOULD HAVE TO BE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF YOUR DECISION MAKING.
NOW THERE'S REALLY TWO KEY
ISSUES FIRST WHAT LEVEL OF
RESERVES DO YOU WANT.
WHAT WHAT KIND OF RESERVES THE
ONE HAVE AT THE END OF THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET YEAR?
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD HAVE
MAXED OUT THE THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT OF TEN
PERCENT.
AND HE ALSO HAS TWO PERCENT IN
JUST WHAT WE CALL DISCRETIONARY
RESERVES.
SO WE HAVE TWELVE PERCENT IN
RESERVES THAT'S A LEVEL WE
HAVEN'T REACHED IN IN IN MY
LIFETIME.
ITS A REALLY REMARKABLE
ACHIEVEMENT IF YOU WERE TO BUY
HAVE THAT KIND OF LEVEL OF
PROTECTION AGAINST ARE ARE VERY
VOLATILE REVENUE.
SYSTEM.
BUT WHAT IS THE RIGHT LEVEL.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE ARGUED IT'S A
LOT WE SHOULD BE A LOT MORE.
IT'S COSTA MENTION THAT  CAN
HAVE A TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR
DOWNTURN PRETTY RAPIDLY.
SOME PEOPLE SUGGESTED WE SHOULD
HAVE GIVEN OUR REVENUE
STRUCTURE.
WHICH HAVE A FIFTEEN OR TWENTY
OR TWENTY FIVE PERCENT RESERVE.
NOT THERE'S THERE'S NO RIGHT
ANSWER TO THIS QUESTION.
IN IN LARGE PART DEPENDS ON YOUR
SORT OF PERSONAL PREFERENCES AND
AND THE WAY THAT YOU PERCEIVE
THINGS DO YOU WANT TO PLAN FOR A
MODERATE RECESSION.
DO YOU WANT A PLAN FOR THE WORST
POSSIBLE RECESSION
WHEN DO YOU THINK IT'S COMING.
SOON OR THREE OR FOUR YEARS DOWN
THE ROAD ALL OF THOSE KIND OF
DECISIONS CAN AFFECT WHAT YOU
THINK IS THE SORT OF IDEAL
RESERVE.
I WOULD SAY THAT GETTING TO AT
LEAST THE TEN PERCENT BSA
MAXIMUM.
IN THE VERY NEAR FUTURE WOULD BE
A VERY IMPORTANT THING TO DO AYE
AYE WHAT AT THE MINIMUM TRIED TO
ACHIEVE THAT.
AND WHETHER YOU GO BEYOND THAT
ARE NOT.
SORT OF IT HAS TO BE YOUR
CALCULUS OF THE VARIOUS FACTORS
THAT I DID MENTION.
YOU CAN EASILY MAKE THE CASE FOR
MORE RESERVES AND IRONICALLY AND
THIS I THIS IS VERY COUNTER
INTUITIVE.
BUT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO MAX OUT THE RESERVE
TO PUT THE THREE AND A HALF
BILLION.
COULD ACTUALLY MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO BUILD
HIGHER RESERVES.
AND WE TELL YOU WHY THAT'S THE
CASE
IF YOU MAX OUT YOUR RESERVE IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE BSA AT TEN
PERCENT.
WHEN YOU GET TO NINETEEN TWENTY
YOU STILL MAY HAVE TO MAKE IN
EFFECT PAYMENTS THAT YOU HAVE TO
SET ASIDE.
FOR RESERVES IN DEBT PAYMENTS
HOWEVER INSTEAD OF GOING TO THE
BSA. THAT MONEY HAS TO BE SPENT
ON CAPITAL OUTLAY.
NOW THAT COULD BE A REALLY GOOD
THING WE HAVE LOTS OF CAPITAL
OUTLAY NEEDS.
BUT WHAT IF YOU WANTED TO BUILD
YOUR RESERVE A FIFTEEN PERCENT.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO MAX
OUT THE BSA MEANS THAT IN AT
NINETEEN TWENTY FOR EXAMPLE YOU
MIGHT HAVE TO SPEND MONEY THAT
YOU COULD SET ASIDE FOR
ADDITIONAL RESERVES. ON CAPITAL
OUTLAY WOULD MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO BUILD
HIGHER RESERVES.
I I I'M NOT RAISING THIS TO AN
IF IN TO BE NEGATIVE ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. IT'S REALLY
MORE JUST TO NOTE THAT BECAUSE
OF ALL THE FORMULAS THAT DRIVE
YOUR BUDGET.
WHETHER IT'S NINETY EIGHT OR
PROP TO PROP NOW FIFTY FIVE
FIFTY SIX.
YOU'RE DECISION MAKING IS MUCH
MORE COMPLICATED IT'S MUCH LESS
INTUITIVE.
WHO'S BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT ALL OF THESE
FORMULAS AND THE WAY THAT THEY
INTERACT OFTENTIMES NOT AN
INTUITIVE WAYS.
SO I MENTIONED THAT IT'S JUST A
REALLY SORT OF INTERESTING
COMPLETELY COUNTER INTO.
INTUITIVE RESULT OF TAKING THE
GOVERNOR'S IN GREEN TO
GOVERNOR'S ACTION
TO MAX OUT YOUR RESERVE IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
LET ME BRIEFLY JUST RAISE A
COUPLE OF OTHER ISSUES.
PROP FIFTY FIVE.
WHICH INCREASED.
HIGH INCOME TAX RATES BUT IT
ALSO HAS THIS PROVISION THAT
BETWEEN ZERO AND TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN ANY HERE COULD BE SET
ASIDE FOR. HEALTH BASICALLY MEDI
CAL.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION'S CALCUL
BY THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CALCULATION THAT WOULD BE ZERO
AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND I
THINK THEY'VE TENTATIVELY
SUGGESTED THERE MIGHT BE SOME
SMALL AMOUNT LESS THAN THREE
HUNDRED MILLION. THAT WOULD GO
TOWARDS MEDI CAL IN NINETEEN
TWENTY.
.
THIS IS NOT A REAL INTUITIVE
FORMULA THAT PROP FIFTY FIVE
REFERENCED.
IT'S VERY COMPLICATED.
AND WHAT THE MEASURE DID IS
BASICALLY GIVE THE
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
PRETTY MUCH FULL DISCRETION TO
INTERPRET THAT AS AS. SELF
SEAFAIR AT.
I THINK THEY MADE A GOOD FAITH
EFFORT BUT I THINK I WOULD JUST
SPEND SOME TIME ON THIS INITIAL
LOOK AT THE WAY THAT THEY'RE
DOING THE PROP FIFTY FIVE
CALCULATION.
BECAUSE IT COULD HAVE KIND OF BE
A PRECEDENT FOR ALL FUTURE
CALCULATIONS
AND WILL OBVIOUSLY BE LOOKING AT
THAT IN.
TRYING TO HELP YOU OUT ON THOSE
CALCULATIONS.
FINALLY EVEN THOUGH THERE'S NOT
A LOT OF MONEY BY THE GOVERNORS
ACCOUNT FOR.
REALLY DISCRETIONARY MATTERS.
A ONE EXCEPTION IS EDUCATION.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE THERE'S
GROWTH THERE BECAUSE REVENUES
ARE HIGHER THERE'S GROWTH IN THE
CURRENT YEAR. THERE'S GROWTH
OVER THE BUDGET YEAR AND IN THE
CURRENT YEAR YOU HAD A LOT OF
ONE TIME MONIES THAT NOW YOU CAN
ALLOCATED THE BUDGET YEAR SO. BY
OUR CALCULATION YOU HAVE OVER
SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT BUDGET THAT TO
ALLOCATE.
FOR VARIOUS PURPOSES K. TWELVE
INCOMMUNICADO ITS PURPOSE.
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE K.
TWELVE SIDE IS ALLOCATING
VIRTUALLY ALL OF THEIR SHARE IN
WAYS THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS. A
APPROVED OF IN THE PAST AND
THAT'S FULLY FUNDING THE LCF AT.
AND GIVING A LARGE AMOUNT OF
BLOCK GRANTS.
ON THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SIDE
THERE ARE LOT MORE DISCRETIONARY
PROPOSES A NEW PROPOSALS THAT MS
COST DIMENSION.
FUNDING FORMULA ONLINE PROGRAM
CTE WE THINK ALL OF THESE
PROPOSALS HAVE MERIT WORTH YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THEY'RE NOT EASY
THERE'S COMPLICATED ISSUES TO
BE.
DEALT WITH AND I THINK IF YOU
WANT TO HAVE
A RESPONSE TO THESE PROPOSALS
AND ENACT THEM IN SOME FORM BY.
BY THE BY THE BUDGET IN JUNE YOU
NEED TO GET GOING EARLY ON THESE
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT
EASY ISSUES.
AND WITH THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN
ALSO HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY.
I THINK MISS TAYLOR WE GO BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A
QUESTION POLL FOR THE PARTNER
FINANCE AND THE OHIO I'LL START
WITH THE MISTRUSTED.
THE I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO AYE
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE PSA I
THINK A LOT OF THE PEOPLE ON THE
DICE ARE BUT IT CERTAINLY
CATALYZE A DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT
THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL. OF
FUNDING IN THE BSA WOULD BE.
AND.
YOU RAISED THE POINT AT THE END
OF YOUR PRESENTATION THAT. A ONE
YEAR RECESSION IS LIKELY TO COST
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
REVENUE WHICH THE BSA WOULD
WOULD NOT COVER.
BUT ALSO IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RECESSION
SCENARIO YOU PROJECTS THAT IN A
MILD RECESSION THE TOTAL LOSS OF
REVENUE WOULD BE ABOUT SEVENTY
BILLION DOLLARS SO OBVIOUSLY.
THIRTEEN OR FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS NINETY SA IS NOT EVEN A
COME CLOSE TO COVER THAT ONE
COVER TWENTY PERCENT SO. I IN
THE OPINION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SHOULD THAT LIMIT BE
RAISED THE CONSTITUTIONAL LIMIT
OF TEN PERCENT OF OF STATE
EXPENDITURES IN THE BSA AND IF
SO WHAT'S AN APPROPRIATE LEVEL
TO RAISE IT TO.
THANK YOU I WOULD ALIGN MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE ANALYST
WHICH IS THAT A RESERVE AMOUNT I
DON'T KNOW THAT THERE IS ANY
MAGIC NUMBER FOR THE RIGHT
RESERVE AMOUNT MAKING SOME OF
THE HOUSE DO YOU. YOU OR HAVE
RISK
A VERSION OR HOW COMFORTABLE YOU
ARE I THINK YOU RAISE A GOOD
POINT AND WE OBVIOUSLY CAUTION
NOT EVEN.
AS GREAT AS IT IS TO REACH THE
TARGET APPROVED BY VOTERS THE
PROPOSITION TWO. IT BUYS YOU
TIME IT WON'T ADDRESS PROBABLY
THE FULL SCOPE OF A RECESSION ON
AS WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST.
I WILL SAY HISTORICALLY A PUTS
US IN A MUCH BETTER POSITION IN
THE STATE HAS BEEN DURING
PREVIOUS RECESSIONS.
ADDITIONALLY IN THE ELSE'S
TALKED ABOUT THIS IN THE PAST I
WOULD JUST REMIND FOLKS THERE'S
ACTUALLY TWO DIFFERENT RESERVE
ACCOUNTS.
A ONE IS THE STATE FUND FOR
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY WE DO
PROPOSE KEEPING MONEY THERE IT'S
MORE ON THE LAW ALLOWS IT HAS
MUCH MORE LIQUIDITY.
VERSES THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACT
SO TO YOUR POINT.
I THINK I WOULD LOOK AT BOTH
ACCOUNTS AS BUILDING A TOTAL
RESERVE AMOUNT WITH REALLY
DIFFERENCE A LOVER'S AVAILABLE
SHOULD SOMETHING HAPPEN WON WITH
MUCH MORE LIQUIDITY ANOTHER
WHICH WOULD PROBABLY INVOLVED
MORE THOUGHTFUL LONGTERM PROCESS
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACT.
THANK YOU AYE MR TAYLOR A.
I'D WANT TALK ABOUT STATE
EXPENDITURES.
THE.
A OBVIOUSLY IT'S EASY FOR
EVERYONE TO DO A VICTORY LAP
OVER YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT
REVENUES ARE UP SO MUCH BUT. I
ALSO THINK THAT SOMETIMES THAT
CALLS ATTENTION AWAY FROM THE
DEGREE TO WHICH STATE
EXPENDITURES HAVE BEEN GROWING
AND IN MY OPINION THEY'VE BEEN
GROWING OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
AT AN ALARMING RATE. IN FACT
ALMOST THREE TIMES THE RATE OF
INFLATION
SO I THOUGHT IS THAT LEVEL OF
EXPENDITURE GROWTH SUSTAINABLE
LONG TERM IN YOUR OPINION.
BUT I.
IT WOULD DEPEND ON WHY THEY'RE
GROWING AS THE DAY ARE THEY
ONGOING OUR DAY YOU TALK ABOUT
THE GENERAL FUND OR JUST GENERAL
FUND AND SPECIAL FUN.
I'M NOT AWARE OF THAT EXACTLY
THE NUMBER THAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO I HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
AT THE ACTUAL NUMBERS.
WELL I THINK HOLISTICALLY I MEAN
IT'S IT'S IT'S A COMBINATION OF
A LOT OF THINGS.
THE EFFECTS OF THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE THAT CHRISTIAN STATE
SALARIES OF THE PENSION FUND
INCREASES.
INTO THE CREASE CONTRIBUTION
FOR THOSE BALL THOSE PUT
TOGETHER PAINT WHAT I CONSIDER
TO BE IN A VERY ALARMING
PICTURE.
I MEAN I THINK THAT'S THE OTHER
SIDE THAT YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT TO NOT ONLY
WHAT HAPPENED STE WHAT IS YOUR
LONG TERM REVENUE STREAM ONCE
YOU TRY TO SMOOTH OUT THE
EFFECTS.
OF CAPITAL GAINS ANOTHER ONE
TIME THINGS
AND YOUR EXPENDITURES STRAINING
AND CAN YOU BRING THOSE THOSE
LINES NEED TO BE BROUGHT
TOGETHER. AYE YOU'RE SUGGESTING
THAT MAYBE THEY'RE NOT OR THAT
WE NEED TO BRING DOWN ONE AS
OPPOSED TO YOU KNOW MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS ON RESERVES TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE FLUCTUATIONS IN
THE OTHER. I KNOW I WOULD
ENTIRELY AGREE WITH YOU HAVE TO
LOOK AT BOTH SIDES. AND YOU WANT
TO BRING THEM IN BALANCE.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
MISS MEDINA.
I I HEARD AND SAW A LOT OF US.
GOVERNORS PLAN FOR EDUCATION
ESPECIALLY AS IT PERTAINS TO K.
TWELVE. AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
BUT I DIDN'T HEAR OR SEE MUCH ON
HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND.
IN THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS BOTH
THE UC REGENTS AND THE CSU
TRUSTEES WILL BE CONSIDERING
TUITION HIKES.
AND IT STRIKES ME THAT WE ARE
GONNA BE ASKING CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
IN BOTH THE CSU AND THE UC TO
PAY HIGHER TUITION.
AT A TIME WHERE AS YOU JUST
PRESENTED TO US CALIFORNIA IS
DOING THE BEST.
FINANCIALLY.
AS YOU STATED.
RETAILER IN YOUR LIFETIME.
AND THAT'S A BIG IRONY TO ME.
ARE IT IS MY UNDERSTOOD AND.
I WILL ASK HOW DO YOU RESPOND AS
THE GOVERNOR'S ADMINISTRATION
SPOT.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I
THINK ONE OF THE KEY COMPONENTS
A A IN THAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE
REVENUES ARE THAT MANY OF THEM
ARE ONE TIME THE NATURE SOME OF
THE GAINS WERE SAYING ON THE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX.
WHICH IS EXTREMELY VOLATILE
REVENUE SOURCE
IN THE MAY REVISION IN OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION CHAPTER WE
SIGNAL TO BOTH THE ISSUE AND YOU
SEE THAT THEY CAN ANTICIPATED
THREE PERCENT INCREASE WHICH IS
WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET.
THE GOVERNOR ALSO INDICATED BOTH
IN HIS PRESS CONFERENCE AS WELL
AS IN OUR PUBLICATION THAT
BEFORE WE PROCEED WITH TUITION
INCREASES WE STILL ARE HOPING
THAT BOTH THE ISSUE WHEN YOU SEE
WILL REDUCE THEIR OVERALL COST
STRUCTURES IN THIS TO NOT SADDLE
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WITH
INCREASED TUITION COSTS.
AND WE CONTINUE TO.
WHAT TO SEE THAT WITH BOTH
SEGMENTS?
TO FOLLOW UP.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE HAD BEEN AN AGREEMENT
REACHED BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR AND
YOU SEE FOR FOUR PERCENT ANNUAL
INCREASE.
BUT THIS YEAR WE'RE ONLY LOOKING
AT A THREE PERCENT INCREASE TO
THE UC BUT.
THOSE WERE A PREVIOUS BUDGET
YOURS IN THE CURRENT BUDGET YEAR
THEY HAVE FOUR PERCENT I BELIEVE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR BEFORE THAT
THEY HAD FOUR PERCENT BUT I
BELIEVE IT'S ON PAGE TWENTY
SEVEN OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
CHAPTER. OF NAY REVISION WE KNOW
TO THREE PERCENT INCREASE FOR
BOTH SEGMENTS SO WHEN YOU SEE
TALKED ABOUT AND ENROLLMENT
GROWTH.
AND NOT KEEPING.
.
AND NOT RAISING TUITION FOUR
PERCENT WAS NEVER THE FIGURE
THAT WAS.
AGREED UPON.
IN PREVIOUS BUDGET YEARS THAT
WAS THE FIGURE THAT WAS AGREED
TO AND NOT IN THE CAR AND NOT
AND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO BETTER.
AND I JUST WANTED.
CLARIFY ONE THING AROUND
ENROLLMENT GROWTH SOON ROMAN
GROWTH. WAS A SEPARATE AGREEMENT
ESPECIALLY PARTICULAR IN
RELATION TO YOU SEE. THAT ARMING
WE STRUCTURED SO THAT WAS THE.
DIFFERENT FROM THERE ARE PERCENT
OF AUGMENTATION.
AT THE AT THIS POINT DAY ARE
ADHERING TO THE AGREEMENT BASED
ON THE. ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT
WE PROVIDED.
IN THE BUDGET THE SHOW GOING IN
CONNECTION.
MR MESSAGES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MS
ACOSTA.
I.
ONCE JOIN THE VICE CHAIR IN IT
EXPRESSING MY APPRECIATION FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET PROPOSAL A PARTICULARLY
AT THIS.
.
A STRONG COMMITMENT TO FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY WHERE THE.
THE STRONG COMMITMENT TO THE
RAINY DAY FUND. AND ALSO.
THE STRONG COMMITMENT TWO R. K.
THROUGH TWELVE OF FINDING. OF
WITH THE FULL FUNDING OF LCF F.
TWO YEARS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
WELL WHAT I AM GONNA CONCERNED
ABOUT HOWEVER IS THAT.
MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE URBAN AS
WELL AS SUBURBAN AS WELL AS
ROLE.
IN THESE GOOD BUDGET TIMES.
ARE PROJECTING DEFICITS.
.
NO TWO YEARS OUT THREE YEARS
OUT.
WITH.
THERE A PARTICULAR THEIR THEIR
RISING PENSION COSTS AND THEIR
RISING SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS.
AND.
.
SO I WANTED TO ASK WHAT WHAT IS
THE GOVERNOR'S.
OFFICES POSITION IN TERMS OF.
YOU KNOW.
IF IF SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
PROJECTING DEFICITS IN THESE CUT
BUDGET TIMES.
WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO DO?
WHEN THE END OF UP ALREADY
RECESSION DOES HIT.
AS THE ALLIES POINTED OUT I
THINK MANY OF YOU ARE PROBABLY
HEARING AS WE ARE AS WELL FROM
BOTH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
SCHOOL BOARDS ABOUT THEIR
PENSION COST.
I THINK MY RESPONSE WOULD BE TO
THINK OF EDUCATION PREVIOUSLY
VERSES NOW IN THE OLD
CATEGORICAL WORLD IT WOULD BE
EXCEEDINGLY DIFFICULT FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ACCOUNT FOR SOME OF
THESE COST THROUGH THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AS WELL
AS CONSOLIDATING MOST
CATEGORICAL.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE MUCH MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS THESE ON
GOING COST
AND SO WE WOULD ENCOURAGE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS USING THIS NEW
FLEXIBILITY AND THIS MASSIVE
INFLUX OF CASH THE THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE. TO LOOK AT ALL OF
THEIR DIFFERENCE.
DEMANDS AND MAKE DECISIONS
ACCORDINGLY WITH THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
OKAY AMEND THAT THAT SOUNDS GOOD
BUT. I JUST HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH ALL OF MY.
LOCAL A SCHOOL BOARD
PRESIDENT'S.
THIS PAST WEEK AND. THEY'RE
THEY'RE BASICALLY WENT WHEN I.
ONE AND YOU KNOW.
THINKING THAT I WOULD BE
DELIVERING GOOD NEWS IN TERMS
OF.
YOU KNOW THE SEVEN STRAIGHT.
A YEAR OF INCREASED QUE THROUGH
TALL FINDING A ALONG WITH YOU
KNOW WHAT I THOUGHT THEY WOULD
APPRECIATE MORE LOCAL CONTROL.
THERE AND THEY ARE THEY THEY
WERE EXPRESSING THEIR
FRUSTRATION THAT. THAT THEY
BASICALLY THAT THE STATE IS THEY
THE WAY THEY SEE IT THE STATE IS
TAKING AWAY MORE THAN THE STATE
IS GIVING.
PRIMARILY IN TERMS OF THE
RAMPING UP OF THE TELSTRA
ERRORS.
PENSION SCHEDULE AND AND SO.
YOU KNOW I I WAS KIND OF TAKEN
ABACK BECAUSE IT WENT THROUGH
SUCH A DISCONNECT BETWEEN. WHAT
FOLKS THERE THAT THE PREVAILING
NARRATIVE HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
WHAT?
MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
FEELING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL SO IS
SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF THAT THERE.
THE.
THE IN THE IN THE PENSION COSTS.
WHAT IS THE GOVERNOR IS SO A
POSITION IN TERMS OF?
ANY CONSIDERATION ABOUT.
.
USING EITHER SOME OF THE.
FUNDS THAT ARE BEING DEVOTED
TOWARD THE.
RAINY DAY FUND OR PERHAPS
ADDITIONAL REVENUES THAT MAY
COME IN THE MAY REVISE.
TOWARD.
RELIEF FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
TERMS OF MEETING THEIR PENSION.
WE HAVEN'T CONTEMPLATED A
SPECIFIC PROPOSAL I KNOW SOME
ADVOCATES HAVE ASKED FOR
PROPOSALS TO INCREASE FUNDING.
TO THINK AS WE MOVE TOWARDS MAY
REVISE OBVIOUSLY WILL JUST THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEED BASED ON
OVERALL REVENUES.
AND OF WE WAS LOOK I THINK DOWN
IN THIS WORLD OF INCREASED
FLEXIBILITY.
AND LOOK AT IT WITH IN THE
OVERALL CONTEXT OF THE BUDGET.
MAY THINK BETWEEN THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACT IN NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING IT SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT TO THE DEGREE PUT MORE
MONEY IN THE GUARANTEED DOES
INCREASE YOUR OUT YOUR COST
BECAUSE YOU'VE INCREASE THE
GUARANTEES WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
IS OUR CALCULATION OF THE
GUARANTEE BASED ON REVENUES. AT
A LIKELY MOVE DURING MAY REVISE
AS WE HAVE MORE INFORMATION ON
REVENUES ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
DECEMBER RECEIPTS.
OF BEING PRETTY HIGH.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER FUNG.
I THINK THIS CHAIR.
I GOT ONE OF FOCUS ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE AND A FORCE
MANAGEMENT.
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND.
WITH THE PASSIVE SP ONE THERE'S
BEEN A FOCUS ON MAINTENANCE.
.
WHAT'S THE DISCUSSION OR THE
ANALYSIS IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH
OF.
THE BUDGET NOW AND MOVING
FORWARD IS GOING TO BE.
ALLOCATED TOWARD NEW HIGHWAY
CAPACITY OR GENERAL PURPOSE
LANES
HOW TO RELIEVE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION.
I THINK YOU ARE OUR PRIORITY ON
THE AS THE ONE FUNDS HAS BEEN
FIX IT FIRST PROJECTS SO REALLY
THOSE THAT ARE READY TO GO.
.
THAT OUR EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS VERSES EXPANSION. I CAN
TELL YOU I HAVE SOME NUMBERS
HERE.
BASED ON ARE I HAVE PROJECTED
INCREASE IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET.
THAT THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS WOULD
REPAIR OVER THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND POTHOLES.
THREE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE LANE MILES OF
CRACKED PAVEMENT FOUR THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SQUALLS
ALSO NOTICED CHIPPED PAVEMENTS.
AND REPAIR ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION.
SQUARE FEET IF BRIDGES.
WE'VE ACCELERATE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHT HIGHWAY AND BRIDGE
PROJECTS WORTH OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS TO DELIVER ONE YEAR
EARLY BETWEEN SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. SO
REALLY OUR FOCUS HAS BEEN ON
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
FIXING THOSE ROADS AYE AND
ACCELERATING PROJECTS THAT WE
CAN A TO GET THE MONEY OUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. WILL THEY
WILL THERE BE A FOCUS IN THE
FUTURE OR.
WILL DEBATE WILL YOU WILL
DIMINISH ENTERTAIN A DISCUSSION
IN TERMS OF HOW TO ALLOCATE SOME
OF THE FUNDS TO NEW GENERAL OF A
GENERAL PURPOSE LANES ARE NEW
HIGHWAY CAPACITY.
THANK YOU SEE BOTH DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
ARE EARLY IN THE PROCESS WE'RE
FOCUSING ON THE MAIN ITS EFFORTS
TO
TRY TO GET OURSELVES BACK. YOU
KNOW GO OUR SOULS CAUGHT UP ON A
LOT OF A MAINTENANCE THAT IS
THAT'S FALLING BEHIND.
ALSO.
MANY OF THE BILL THE LARGER.
VOTE LOOK SHOT PROJECTS A
REHABILITATION PROJECTS
THOSE TAKE LONGER TIME TO TO GET
PLAN TO GET DONE THAT NORMALLY
SO IF FOUR FIVE SECURE PROJECTS.
IN ADDITION TO THAT THERE'S
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR.
CONGESTED CORRIDOR PROGRAMS
THIS FUNDING AVAILABLE OTHER
SNOW TUNER MILLION DOLLARS YEAR
FOR CONGESTED CORRIDORS. THERE'S
TWENTY FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR FOR COMMUTER CORRIDORS.
YET THIS MONEY ALONG WITH THE
THE MONEY THAT'S GONNA BE
AVAILABLE FOR ON THE
REHABILITATION PROJECTS.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND AND THEN
SHIFT MORE TOWARDS THE THE
PROJECTS PROJECTS ARE MORE
READY.
THAT MONEY THEN WE'LL LOOK AT
PROJECTS THAT HAVE.
THAT THE CALL BENEFITS OF SOME
CAPACITY INCREASE
THAT COME ALONG WITH THE
REHABILITATION JUST SO I
UNDERSTAND AND MAYBE CAN CLARIFY
THIS FOR ME MYERS AND THAT IS
THAT THE CONGESTED CORRIDORS
FINDING THERE'S A PROHIBITION TO
USE ANY OF THOSE FUNDS FOR
GENERAL PURPOSE LANES.
IS THAT CORRECT.
I DON'T LIKE THE THE.
.
THE GUIDELINES FOR USE OF THOSE
OF THOSE FUNDS ARE ARE STILL
BEING DEVELOPED.
BUT THERE ISN'T ALWAYS I MEAN
YOU CAN YOU CAN ACHIEVE
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY NOT
NECESSARILY BY ALWAYS ADDING TO
SHOW MIGHT SOMETIMES IT'S IT'S
COORDINATING THE LANE SOMETIMES
IT'S.
YOU KNOW COORDINATING THE FLOW
OF TRAFFIC SO THERE'S A LOT MORE
THAT GOES INTO JUNE BIT TO AND
BEEN.
JUST ADDING ADDITIONAL POINTS
NOW ALL THE PROJECTS ARE PROVED
TO SEE TC'S PROCESS SO THERE
WILL BE. GUIDELINES FOR WITH.
IT WHAT MAKES THE PROJECTS WHAT
WHAT PROJECTS ARE THE MOST
ADVANTAGEOUS AND THEY'LL HAVE
RESULTS THAT THEY'LL HAVE TO
MEASURE TO TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BURKE CHEATING THOSE RESULTS SO.
YOU KNOW REDUCING CONGESTION IS
IS THE MAIN YOU KNOW THE MAIN
RESULT THAT'S.
BEING LOOKED FOR OUT OF THOSE
PARTICULAR FUNDS OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND ANSWERS OF. LOVE
MOVING TO WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION.
TO. ALLOCATE SOME FUNDING TO.
MORE SURFACE WATER STORAGE.
I HAVE MY STAFF THAT APPEAR
PROVIDES MORE SPECIFICS BUT AS I
TESTIFIED EARLIER WE DO HAVE A
POSTAL TWO. CAN A FOR LACK OF A
BETTER TERM PRE APPROPRIATE SOME
OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES BONDS
DOLLARS ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS.
ON SOME OF THAT OBVIOUSLY IS FOR
OUR WATER AND THAT'LL UNISOM.
A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
THE VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION
ONE SHE'S ME MATT ARMY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
COUPLE YEARS AGO THE VOTERS
APPROVED PROPOSITION ONE WHICH
WAS A WATER BOND IN WITH IN THAT
PROPOSITION ONE OF BOND INCLUDED
I BELIEVE WAS ABOUT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS OF.
FUNDING FOR.
ADDITIONAL SURFACE STORAGE THAT
WAS CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED IN
THE CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION.
I BELIEVE JUST RECENTLY ADOPTED
ITS GUIDELINES.
TO GOVERN THE USE OF THAT AND
SO.
MY UNDERSTANDING OF THAT THE
CURRENT PROCESSES THAT YOU GET
YOURS GOING THROUGH THE. PROCESS
OF EVALUATING APPLICATIONS FOR
THAT OKAY WELL JUST ECHO TO AN
ANALYST IS SAYING I THINK WE DO.
WANT TO FOCUS MORE LONG TERM
AND.
THE CONCERN I THINK FOR THE A
LOT OF THOSE FUNDS IS THAT.
THEY'RE GOING FOR HIM.
A LOT OF PROJECTS BUT NOT ONES
THAT OF SUBSTANTIAL SIZE TO
WHERE WE CAN WITH IT WHETHER.
THROUGH THE LARGE DROUGHT AS
WE'VE EXPERIENCE HISTORICALLY SO
IN TERMS OF LIKE PROJECTS LIKE
SITES ARE TEMPERANCE.
WHERE IT WILL HAVE SOME
SUBSTANTIAL BENEFITS OF THE SAKE
OF WHERE THEY ARE SIZABLE
INVESTMENTS AND SO I DON'T KNOW
IF THE ADMINISTRATION IS
DISCUSSING?
IN INVESTING SOME OF THE.
BUT MAKING AN INVESTMENT FROM
THE BUDGET IN TERMS OF DOING
LARGE SCALE WATER STORAGE.
A LIKE I SAID I THINK THE.
GIVEN THE SIZEABLE INVESTMENT
OF PROPOSITION ONE.
THAT DOES REFLECT A IN THAT WAS
PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S OF
WATER ACTION PLAN.
I SHOULD SAY TOO SO THE
ADMINISTRATION THROUGH ITS WATER
ACTION PLAN IN SUPPORT OF
PROPOSITION ONE HAS.
DEMONSTRATED A COMMITMENT FOR
ADDITIONAL STORAGE CAPACITY
COMBINED WITH WATER CONSERVATION
COMBINED WITH BETTER GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT KIND OF.
.
ALL OF THE ABOVE TYPE.
APPROACH TO WATER AND IF I MAY
THEM OFF OF THE ANALYST COMMENT
ONE OF THE. SHE'S CAUTIONED I
THINK IT'S A BENEFIT ONE OF THE
BENEFITS OF REACHING THE
CONSTITUTIONAL TARGET OF
PROPOSITION TWO IS THAT IN
FUTURE YEARS ANY DOLLARS THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN DEPOSITED INTO
THE BUDGET STABILIZATION ACT OR
UTILIZED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO THEORETICALLY IF THE ENACTED
BUDGET REACHES THAT TEN PERCENT
CONSTITUTIONAL. A HOT TARGET YOU
WOULD HAVE FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR
A VARIETY OF INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS.
THANK YOU AND LASTLY JUST IN FUN
FORCE MANAGEMENT.
OUT OF SOMEONE ELSE IS GONNA
RUN APPEAR AND ANSWER SOME
QUESTIONS SO I APOLOGIZE LIKE. I
KNOW THAT THE BUDGET HAS FOCUSED
A LOT ON FIRE PROTECTION BUT IN
TERMS OF PREVENTION.
AND AND HEALTHY FORESTS.
.
HOW MUCH IS ALLOCATED TOWARD?
THE FORCE MANAGEMENT AND HOW
MUCH IS.
NEEDED TO ACTUALLY PREVENT A LOT
OF THESE HOW CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES ARE VERY.
WE ACTUALLY MADE A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN FORCE
MANAGEMENT THROUGH THE CAP AND
TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN IN THE
CURRENT YEAR OVER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. WE STOP THE
STATE RESPONSE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY AREA FEE AND HAVE
FACT FILLED ALL OF THOSE
ACTIVITIES WHICH INCLUDE FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. IN ADDITION AND
THERE'S TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WITH A VERY HEALTHY
EXPENDITURE PERIOD FOR FOREST
MANAGEMENT.
ACTIVITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SO TRADITIONALLY HOME OR
PREVIOUSLY WE HAD HAD TREE
MORTALITY DOLLAR SPECIFICALLY IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN THE
CURRENT YEAR IT'S ACTUALLY THE
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN.
WITH JUST LAST QUESTION I I
THINK HE WAS CHAIR.
IN TERMS OF LIKE TREE MORTALITY
AND.
I THINK A LOT OF THESE
PROBLEMS ARE ARE WORSENING AND I
THINK THAT THE FIRES ARE GOING
LARGER.
IN SO WE OUT SEE CLEARLY NEED
TO DO A LOT MORE IN FORCE
MANAGEMENT AND AND AND.
IT IS THAT IS TWO HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS ENOUGH I GUESS
IS THE QUESTION IS THERE AN
ANALYSIS FROM CAL FIRE.
FROM ANY OTHER ANALYSTS ARE
DEPARTMENT THAT THAT.
GIVES US A SENSE OF IS THERE A
GAP THAT WE NEED TO.
TO MEET
TO ADDRESS THAT THIS THIS
GROWING PROBLEM. I WOULD POINT
TO SOME OTHER ALLOCATION
PROPOSAL THAT WE HAVE OUTSIDE OF
THE CAP AND TRADE A THINK WE TRY
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR WHAT WE CALL THE NEW NORMAL
WITH CALIFORNIA ARE. THEY REALLY
ARE MOVING TO REALLY A TWELVE
MONTH FIRE SEASON SO WE TRY TO
ACCOMMODATE THEIR SOCKS STOPPING
THROUGH OUR BUDGET PROPOSAL.
DISSING WE HAVE SOME PROPOSALS
TO BRING HELICOPTERS AND UPDATE
SOME OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED HAD TO FIGHT FOREST FIRES
AS WELL AS PREVENT THEM. SO I
THINK WE'VE MADE SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN THIS
AREA AND WE'RE CONTINUING THOSE
IN OUR PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE MISSING OUT.
THINK YOU AT A COUPLE COMMENTS
AND THEN SOME QUESTIONS AND ON
THE EDUCATION SIDE AND I WANT TO
ECHO THE VOICES OF THE.
THOSE THAT HAVE TALKED ABOUT HOW
OUR LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND THEIR FEELINGS AND
PERSPECTIVE ON THE BUDGET IS NOT
A LYING TO AND THIS YOU KNOW THE
CAPITAL STATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PERSPECTIVE I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HEAR LOUD AND
CLEAR SO. I HOPE THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WILL BE I WILL
CONTINUE.
BECAUSE AIDS TO VERY DIFFERENT
FEELINGS ON IT OUTLOOKS
ON AND THE BUDGET. AND
ADDITIONALLY I I WANT TO.
.
I COMMEND THE CONSIDERATION FOR
KIND OF THE REDESIGN OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FUNDING I KNOW
THAT THE LA ALSO DID A REPORT
RECENTLY THAT LOOKED. ON A
LITTLE BIT MORE AT WHAT CATEGORY
CLOSE LOOK LIKE WHO THE SERVE
WITH THE DON'T SERVE. AND AND SO
I THINK THAT THE AND SEEMS A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT CAME OUT OF
THAT REPORT IN THERE. AND I
THINK IS.
INTERESTING AND I DO HOPE THAT
IN.
BUDGETS UP TO WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE THAT.
ABOUT THAT PARTICULAR PIECE
AND I ALSO HOPE THAT IN BUDGETS
OF TO AND IN HIGHER ED.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THE ONLINE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I'M TO
UNDERSTAND.
REALLY IF THAT'S THE VEHICLE TO
ACHIEVE NOT ONLY DEGREES BUT
DEGREES FOR THOSE THAT ARE MOST
UNDERSERVED.
AT PARTICULARLY IN DESERT AREAS
OF HIGHER AD SO I DO HOPE THAT
THOSE TWO COMMITTEES I WILL
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION.
MY QUESTION IS ABOUT THE STATE
FUND FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY.
YEAH WE JUST I HEARD AT. THAT.
YOU DESCRIBE IT HELLFIRE IS NO
LONGER PAPA GOING TO BE LOOKED
AT HAS A SEASONAL BUT YEAR
ROUND.
OUR GOVERNOR ON DECEMBER
NINETEENTH WAS IN THE THOMAS
FIRE AREA.
WHICH I REPRESENT.
AND TALKED ABOUT THIS BEING THE
NEW NORMAL SO MY QUESTION IS IF
THIS IS THE NEW NORMAL DO WE USE
THE STATE FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY WHICH IS ONE OF THE
CHIU.
.
BUDGET AREAS YOU DESCRIBED AS
RESERVES.
TO BE USED FOR EMERGENCY AS THE
VEHICLE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THIS
IF THIS IS THE NEW NORMAL DO WE
NEED TO BREAK CONSIDER.
THE IMPACT THAT THE NEW NORMAL
HAS
I'M ON THE BUDGET AND TO REALLY
LOOK AT IT IN TERMS OF A RESERVE
OR IS THIS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
RETHINK.
HOW THE STATE IS GOING TO
RESPOND TO NATURAL DISASTERS AT
A MUCH BROADER LEVEL?
THANK YOU I THINK WE'VE
ATTEMPTED TO DO BOTH.
I THINK WE TRY TO ADJUST THE
STOCKING LEVELS AT CAL FIRE. OH
YES AND SOME OF OUR OTHER FIRST
RESPONDERS.
IT'S HARD FOR US TO PROTECT
OBVIOUSLY WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
I CAN TELL YOU IN THE BUDGETS
THAT I'VE BEEN INVOLVED AND
WE'VE TRIED DROUGHT WE'VE HAD
FLOODING HOW FIRES MUDSLIDES SO
IT CERTAINLY. SEEMS TO BE MORE
THE CASE THE NOTS.
AND ADDITIONALLY HAD SOMETHING
THE COMPOUNDS ARE EMERGENCY
RESPONSES THAT LIKELY MUCH OF
THIS WILL BE REIMBURSED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THAT IS A
LONGER. TERM PROCESS THAT WE GO
THROUGH WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO IN SOME WAYS THE
AS AT THE U. IS IS KIND OF
PERFECTLY PLACED ACTUALLY TO
HELP US WITH THE SHORT INFUSIONS
OF CASH TO MAKE SURE THAT ARE A
MERCHANT THE RESPONSE.
IS QUICK IS TIMELY WELL AS WELL
AS RECOVERY FRANKLY THROUGH THE
JAIL BC PROCESS WE'VE NOTIFIED
THE LEGISLATURE OF THINGS SUCH
AS HAZARDOUS WASTE REMOVAL
THINGS THAT NEED TO HAPPEN RIGHT
AWAY BEFORE THESE COMMUNITIES
CAN REALLY BEGIN TO REBUILD.
SO I THINK IT'S A TWO FOLD
APPROACH LOOKING AT OUR OVERALL
STAFFING LEVELS.
BASED ON HISTORIC TRENDS WHICH
SEEMS TO BE CHANGING AS WE CALL
THE NEW NORMAL. AS WELL AS AND
UTILIZING OUR.
SFE YOU FOR THE THINGS THAT
INVARIABLY WILL HAPPEN.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS YOU KNOW
THERE WAS A HORRIBLE HEPATITIS
OUTBREAK IN SAN DIEGO WE ALSO
SEND SOME FUNDING THERE TO HELP
WITH THAT. SO THERE IS.
THE BUDGET IS A FLUID PROCESS
HOME OBVIOUSLY WE PASSED IT IN
JUNE BUT THINGS HAPPEN
EMERGENCIES PUBLIC HEALTH. ON
NATURAL DISASTERS HAPPEN IN THE
US AT THE U. HELPS US ADDRESS
THOSE IN A REAL TIME MANNER.
A I WOULD JUST ADD TO.
TO MISS COST IS A DISCUSSION
THAT ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS
THAT WE DO TO ADDRESS KIND OF
THIS NEW NORMAL FROM A BUDGETARY
STANDPOINT.
IS THAT CALIFORNIA'S.
BUDGET HAS AN ITEM IN AND
CALLED THE EMERGENCY FUND THE
FUND IT'S KIND OF A SHORTHAND.
AND IT REFLECTS
WHAT THE A FIVE YEAR AVERAGE OF
EMERGENCY.
WHILE FIRE SUPPRESSION COSTS
HAVE BEEN
IN AS YOU CAN IMAGINE AFTER A
SEVERE DROUGHT OF HISTORIC
PROPORTIONS.
THE AMOUNT THAT.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS BUDGETING
IN THE FUND HAS GROWN A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS SO THE BUDGET NOT
ONLY HAS THE.
SIZEABLE RESERVE TO ADDRESS
THESE UNCERTAINTIES BUT IS ALSO
A BUDGETING WITHIN THIS
EMERGENCY FUND ITEM. A HIGHER
AMOUNT TO REFLECT THIS.
THIS NORM.
AND SO FOR THAT ESSAY FOR YOU
FUNDS IT DO YOU FEEL THAT I MEAN
JUST IN THE SAME WAY WE ARE
RECONSIDERING. AND THE BSA
COMMITMENT AND WHETHER THAT
SHOULD BE MORE THANTHE ALLOTTED.
IS THERE VALUE TO RECONSIDER
THAT AS WELL FOR THE AND SAFE
SFE YOU FUNDS.
THIS WILL BE ANOTHER ITEM THAT
WILL LOOK AT ME REVISE AYE IT'S
LARGELY DRIVEN BY OVERALL
REVENUES WHAT WE KNOW OUR
EXISTING ON GOING COSTS ARE
INCLUDING IN THE GUARANTEE WHAT
PROPOSITION TWO REQUIRES AND SO
AS WE REEVALUATE REVENUES GOING
INTO MAY REVISE WILL LOOK ASSET
TO YOU AS. WELL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CABALLERO.
I THINK MISTER CHAIR I AM
EVERYONE AT SECOND WHAT'S BEEN
SAID BY MY COLLEAGUES IN REGARDS
TO THE GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO
IT.
PRUDENT BUDGETING PROCESS I
UNDERSTOOD THE PRINCIPLE YOU
WERE DISCUSSING I JUST COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND THE NUMBERS SO IT IT
MAY BE HELPFUL IF YOU COULD DO A
ONE PAGER IF THAT'S AT ALL
POSSIBLE WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT.
EITHER CONSTITUTIONAL OR
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS.
SO THAT WE CAN UNDERSTAND WHEN
WE PUSH A BUTTON IN ONE SPOT OR
PHIL.
APART IN ONCE BUT WHAT IT DOES
TO THE OVERALL EXPECTATION THE
COMING YEAR BECAUSE I I THINK
THAT. THE POINT YOU MADE IS.
IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT I COULD
REPEAT IT IN IF I COULDN'T CAN'T
REPEAT IT THEN I DON'T KNOW HOW
TO AVOID IT SO IF YOU COULD GET
THAT TO A SAID BEATRIZ ACTITUD.
.
I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE.
.
THE FIRE ISSUE IN PARTICULAR AS
IT RELATES TO HUNDRED AND TWO
MILLION DEAD OR DYING TREES.
THERE IS NO QUESTION IN MY MIND
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK VERY
CAREFULLY AT POLICY CHANGES TO
ALLOW US TO GET THOSE TREES.
THAT ARE FALLING DOWN AND
CREATING A GREENHOUSE GAS.
EXPLOSION AND.
WITH THE DETERIORATION OF THE
PARK UP AND PUT THEM TO GOOD USE
AND I THINK THERE'S THAT REALLY
WILL HELP RURAL CALIFORNIA. EMAM
TURN TALKING ABOUT THAT BIOMASS
BUT THERE'S SOME SOME CHANGES
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN. IN THAT
REGARD AND.
I THINK WE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
ADDRESS IT BECAUSE.
THE LOSS OF PROPERTY AND LIFE.
BECAUSE OF THIS NEW NORMAL IS
UNACCEPTABLE MCCARTY DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN.
.
PROTECT AS MUCH AS WE CAN THE
THE FUEL SOURCE THAT REALLY HAS
THESE GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND
WHAT OUR EXPECTATIONS ARE. SO I
DON'T HAVE A QUESTION REGARD
THAT I JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE
IT IS AN ISSUE THAT. I'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING VERY CAREFULLY AND
CLOSELY AND.
AND IF IT'S IT'S MORE OF A
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER NOT
TAKING CARE OF THESE.
DEAD AND DYING TREES BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE LOSS OF LIFE AND
AND PROPERTIES IS DEVASTATING SO
WE GOT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
WANNA MOVE REAL QUICKLY SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE. WOMAN WHO RAN
UP ON.
I'M ON THE COURT SYSTEM AND I
AND I I I I WANT TO TALK I HAVE
TWO QUESTIONS THAT THAT'S ONE OF
THEM.
BUT WITH THE BUDGET USES THEIR
WORKLOAD BASED ALLOCATION AND
FINING METHODOLOGY UP HAD
EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH.
MY LOCAL COURTS AND THAT.
METHODOLOGY HURTS.
SMALL WORLD. COUNTY COURT COURT
SYSTEMS AND.
CURRENTLY SAM BENITO COUNTY IS
LAYING OFF
A LONG TIME STAFF.
OR A CREATING PART TIME JOBS FOR
THEM BECAUSE THEY CAN NO LONGER.
AFFORD TO KEEP THEM ON STAFF AND
SO IT'S THAT FUNDING FORMULA
THAT WEIGHS.
DEVELOPED AS I UNDERSTAND IT
DURING THE DOWNTURN IN THE
ECONOMY AS A SOLUTION TO KIND
EQUALIZE THE FUNDING. AND I
THINK IT IT DOWN I'D LIKE TO TO
LOOK AT THAT FUNDING FORMULA TO
DETERMINE WHETHER IT REALLY. IS
THE CORRECT FORMULA.
ALL.
IMAGE ARTIST'S DEPARTMENT
FINANCE I THINK THAT ON YES I
AGREE WORK FIRST ARE THE
WORKLOAD ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY.
WAS DEVELOPED A TIME WHEN THE
COURTS WERE AND STRUGGLING
FINANCIALLY. AND I THINK WHAT
THIS IS ATTEMPTING TO DO IS TO
READJUST.
THE AND ALLOCATIONS BASED ON THE
NEW AVERAGE CASE WAIT BY COURT.
SO SAN BENITO WAS ACTUALLY A LOT
OF THE CASE WAIT.
I AM RIGHT NOW IN THEIR AND
SERENE TERMS THEY'RE FUNNY
METHODOLOGY THERE ARE ABOUT
EIGHTY ONE POINT SEVEN WHERE THE
AVERAGE CASE WEIGHT IS SEVENTY
SIX POINT NINE.
SO THEY'RE A LITTLE BIT HIGHER
THAN THE AVERAGE I UNDERSTAND
YOUR POINT. AND CERTAINLY THINK
A LOT OF COURTS ARE STILL
EXPERIENCING THOSE I'M STAFFING
ISSUES WE DON'T AND WE AGREE
THAT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY A
BUDGET A METHODOLOGY. BUT FOR
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
BASELINE IT MADE SENSE FOR US TO
USE SOME KIND OF STANDARD METRIC
IN THIS CASE IT WAS. THE MOST
RECENT UPDATED I HAVE KEY
SWEETS.
SO I AM JUST WANNA EMPHASIZE
THAT OF THEIR CERTAIN
EXPECTATIONS THAT WE HAVE OF OUR
COURT SYSTEM. AND IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOU'RE A BIG COUNTY OR
SMALL COUNTY WE STILL HAVE
EXPECTATIONS.
WHEN THOSE WHEN YOU CAN'T MEET
THE MANY LONGER AND YOU'RE
STARTING TO LAY OFF STAFF.
BEDDED BEEN AROUND FOR A REALLY
LONG TIME OR CUT DID THE HOURS
THAT THE CLERK'S OFFICE IS OPEN
THEN IT'S IT IT REALLY HAS AN
IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITY SO I
THOUGHT SEEMS TO ME. UP AND WE
TALK ABOUT THIS MORE THAT THERE
SHOULD BE AT LEAST A BASE
FORMULA. THAT PROVIDES. ADEQUATE
STAFFING FOR THE COURTS TO BE
ABLE TO.
SERVE THE FUNCTIONS SOME BASIC
FUNCTIONS AND THEN WE LOOK AT
THE CASE LOAD IN THE KIND OF.
UP THE SERIOUSNESS OF CASES AND.
WHAT THEY'RE OF RESOURCES ARE
IN THAT PARTICULAR A COMMUNITY
AS WELL SO? I THINK THAT THAT
PARTICULAR FORMULA HAS SOME
PROBLEMS FOR ME AND I JUST
WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT AND
THEN ALSO. THE.
FOR THE FUNDING OF THE COURTS A
NUMBER OF COURT HOUSES THAT
WERE.
IN THE PLANNING STAGES WERE.
WERE DELAYED UP AND THEY BEEN
DELAYED TO THE DOWNTURN IN THE
ECONOMY IT IS THERE A SCHEDULE.
FOR. THE NUMBER OF COURTHOUSES
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS IT WOULD
MOVE FORWARD AND DO WE KNOW.
ABOUT WHERE THAT WOULD BE. THAT
I MET HER THAT I KNOW OVER TO
ANDREAS HER FOR HER CAPITAL
OUTLAY UNIT BUT HE DID ALSO WANT
TO MENTION JUST IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR OTHER QUESTION ABOUT THE
EQUALIZATION OF COURTS. IS IN
ADDITION TO THE BRING EVERYBODY
UP TO THAT STANDARD KEY SWEET
BASELINE WE HAVE THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S IN
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS THAT WILL
ALLOW THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
SET PRIORITIES ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS. WE ANTICIPATE THAT THEY
WILL PROBABLY DISTRIBUTE AND
MORE EQUITABLY ACROSS THE STATE
AND BASED ON THEIR NEEDS AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE. ISSUE WILL BE
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AND I WOULD NOT ON THE PORT
CONSTRUCTION OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
THE MAJOR PROPOSE ON BEHALF OF
THE ADMINISTRATION TO UTILIZE
WHAT'S LEFT IN IT.
AND TO AUTHORIZE LEASE REVENUE
BONDS.
THE TEN PROJECTS THAT WE'RE
PUTTING FORWARD AS PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND AND MY COLLEAGUE
CAN TALK TO AT WAR WITH THOSE
THAT WERE FURTHER ALONG IN THEIR
PLANNING PROCESS THOSE THAT WERE
REALLY READY TO GO.
STANDARDS ARE FOR A DEPARTMENT
FINANCE THAT'S CORRECT WE HAVE.
TEN PROJECT PROPOSED AS AND.
AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN
PROJECTS THAT ARE POP.
ON THE OVERALL LIST OF IT
MEDIAN CRITICAL NEEDS PROJECTS
FOR THE COURTS AND.
DOES IT WOULD NOT BE READY FOR
CONSTRUCTION FOR ANOTHER FIVE
MINIMUM OF TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OF
THOSE MAY BE CONSIDERED IN
FUTURE BUDGETS.
SO IT DO YOU HAVE A LIST OF
THOSE PARTICULAR PROJECTS CAN
YOU CAN YOU TELL ME IF THE SOUTH
MONTEREY COUNTY IS IS PART OF
THE TENER PART OF THE LATER.
NUMBERS IN THE REASON I SAY THAT
IS THAT.
OUR OUR COUNTY IS.
IT.
THAT PARTICULAR COURT HOUSES
KIND OF BEEN IN THE PLANS FOR A
LONG TIME IT.
THE COURT CLOSED THE SOUTH
COUNTY COURTHOUSE A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO SO EVERYBODY HAS TO
TRAVEL IN ITS.
BOB.
FAIRLY ISOLATED.
UP TO SALINAS HER OVER TO
MONTEREY COUNTY TO GET JUSTICE
AND SO THAT COURTHOUSE IS PRETTY
IMPORTANT TO TO UP TO MY
DISTRICT.
THANK YOU AND NO IT IS NOT PART
OF THE LIST THAT WOULD BE READY
FOR CONSTRUCTION OKAY WITHIN.
THE TIME THAT TIME THE TEN THAT
YOU WAS
IT I THOUGHT IT IS NOT. ON THE
LIST OF THE ADDITIONAL SEVEN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER.
BUSINESS COURSES WITH COSTA NOW
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DISCUSSES
INSTANTLY. THE CALIFORNIA
CONFLICTS TAX CREDIT. PROPOSED
CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM.
THE ADMINISTRATION TALK ABOUT
BUT THE MINUTE PROGRAM LOOK
LIKE.
SPECIFICALLY THE SMALL BUSINESS
PORTION.
THAT'S THE ONE PORTION WE OWE
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON I WE'RE
STILL WORKING THROUGH THAT THE
ALLIES HAD SOME COMMENTS ABOUT
THAT PARTICULAR PORTION OF HE.
I CHECKED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION SO WE DO
HOPE IN THE COMING WEEKS TO
PROVIDE YOU MORE DETAIL ABOUT
THAT PORTION OF THE PROPOSAL.
DID YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PARIS.
THANK YOU THANK WAS CHAIRMAN.
I WANT TO. FOLLOW UP A LITTLE
BIT ON MEMBER FUNCTION QUESTION
WITH RESPECT CAPACITY.
I WANT FOCUS PRINTS UPS
SPECIFICALLY ON A HIGHWAY NINETY
NINE.
NOT IT IS. ARGUABLY THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT THAT COMMERCIAL.
.
ROUTE IT IS SO SIGNIFICANT THAT
WITH RESPECT TO TRAFFIC.
AS WELL.
.
IS THERE ANYTHING IN THIS
BUDGET.
OR ANYTHING IN THE S. B. ONE.
TAX INCREASE.
THAT WOULD PRIORITIZE FOR
ACCELERATE.
BRINGING THE TWO LANE NORTH
SOUTH.
PINCH POINTS ON NINETY NINE UP
TO.
THREE LANE NORTH SOUTH THE
REASON I POINT THAT OUT IS
RATHER OBVIOUS.
WHEN NORTH SOUTH TRAFFIC IS IN
THREE LANDS.
ARE THERE AT THE LIMIT.
.
IT'S SAFER.
IT THIS OBVIOUSLY SIGNIFICANT
FLOW OF OF TRAFFIC WHEN IT GOES
DOWN TO THE. THAT PINCH POINTS.
A TWO LANE PINCH POINTS
THE BRIGHT LIGHTS COME ON THE
TRAFFIC SLOWS DOWN. THE.
FENDER BENDERS GO UP.
AND THE FRUSTRATION OF DRIVERS.
GO UP AS WELL.
.
ANYTHING AT ALL THAT.
COULD.
ENCOURAGE THOSE OF US WHO
REPRESENT.
THE NINETY NINE.
THAT SOME OF THE TAX INCREASES
IN SP ONE.
AND SOME OF THE PRIORITIES OF
THE OF THE GOVERNOR WOULD
INCLUDE DATA PRIORITIZING AND
ACCELERATING.
BUT THE LATE ADDITIONS TO NINETY
NINE.
I MEAN AS FAR AS THE OF THEM
STEVE AUSTIN DEPARTMENT FINANCES
FAR AS THE.
THE THE ACTUAL FUNDING OF THE
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS THAT ARE TO
BE CHOSEN. IN ALL THE PROJECTS A
THREE PROBE THE PROGRAM THROUGH
THE CTS.
SO THE THE CHOICE OF WHICH
PROJECTS TO TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
FIRST OR TO TO PROGRAM.
IT IS MADE BY THEM HOWEVER
THERE IS A EITHER THERE'S FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
COMBINED AVAILABLE EVERY YEAR.
SPECIFICALLY FOR.
COMMUTER CORRIDORS AND TRADE
QUARTER ENHANCEMENT.
SO THOUGH THOSE FUNDING BUT
THOSE THINGS NEW.
YET LET'S STRAIGHTEN IT.
ENTIRELY FROM THE NEW S. B. ONE
FUNDS.
THERE'S ALSO A THE.
THE ADDITIONAL SB ONE FUNDS AS
ALLOWED THE THE SHOP PROGRAM TO
GO FROM.
AN ANNUAL CAPACITY OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS TO.
OVER FOUR BILLION DOLLARS TO
FOUR POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS
HERE SO.
THERE'S THAT PASSED THE BUILTIN
THERE YOU KNOW BEGINNING AND IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND MOVING
FORWARD.
SO THE PROJECTS THAT WERE
ALREADY IN THE SHOP.
AMOUNTED TO ABOUT TWO POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS SO. THERE'S THAT
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS AND THEN YOU KNOW
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
MOVING ON AT LEAST IN THE THE
THE CHOP BEING A FOR YOUR.
FOR YOUR LISTA PROJECTS SO.
THERE'S A LOT OF CAPACITY FOR A
LOT OF PROJECTS.
AND.
AND THEN.
DID THE ATTEMPT NORMALLY ON
THESE PROJECTS IS TO TRY TO
UTILIZE AS MANY AS FUNDS SOURCES
AND IT AND GET SYNERGY AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE IF YOU CAN.
YOU KNOW IF YOU CAN MAKE A
PROJECT IF OU CAN IF YOU CAN
TOUCH THE ROAD ONCE AND TAKE
CARE OF MANY PROBLEMS YOU CAN.
ON THEIR SCENTED THERE'S ALWAYS
ATTEMPTED DO THAT SO.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
PRIORITIZATION OF INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS THAT'S PROBABLY YOU
KNOW SOMETHING WE COULD.
THE DISCUSS AND.
THINKING SUBCOMMITTEE WHEN WE
HAVE.
CALTRANS OR SEEK TO SEE
AVAILABLE.
BUT I DO KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR. THAT
TYPE.
THEM WE BUT.
QUERY DOUBT.
CALTRANS WITH RESPECT TO
EXISTING OF PIPELINE.
EXPANSION ARM ON THE NINETY
NINE AND I. WERE STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF GATHERING INFORMATION
BUT I FIND WHAT WE'VE READ.
RECEIVED.
SO FAR.
REALLY IS LIMITED.
MINIMAL AND SPOTTY.
AND IF YOU.
WERE TO. LOOK AT.
THE SIGNIFICANT PINCH POINTS
NORTH AND SOUTH.
THEY ARE THEY ARE THAT DO JUST
IT'S AS IF THE NO THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CORRIDOR IN THE
STATE.
AFTER NORTH SOUTH THEIR
TRANSPORTATION.
SORT OF IS GETTING I THINK THE.
THE BACKSEAT TO ALL OF THIS.
SO WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT SEEING A
LOT OF THAT.
.
SO FAR NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO I'M
I'M CONCERNED. THAT IT SEEMS TO
ME THERE SOME AMBIGUOUS NESS
HERE WITH RESPECT TO HOW MUCH
MONEY IS LIMITED FOR CAPACITY
IMPROVEMENT AND CONGESTION.
MITIGATION.
AND SO I I REALLY THINK THAT.
OF WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
INFRASTRUCTURE EXPENDITURE AND
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT BANG FOR
THE BUCK AND WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT SAFETY AND ALL THAT.
FOR THIS NINETY NINE CORRIDOR
NEEDS TO BE THREE LANES NORTH
SOUTH FROM A BAKERSFIELD TO
SACRAMENTO FOR A WHOLE RAFT OF
OF REASONS.
ALONG THOSE CORRIDORS ARE
SIGNIFICANT SELF HELP COUNTIES.
A FRESNO BEING ONE OF THE
MOTHERS.
AND SO HAVE I APPRECIATE.
.
THE INVITATION.
TO EXPLORE THESE IN MORE DETAIL
IN THE BUDGET SUB THREE AND.
BUT WE WILL BE DOING THAT.
IN AN EFFORT TO REALLY GET TO
AN ACCELERATION.
AND A PRIVATIZATION.
OF THE KIND OF FOR SPENDING
THAT WOULD IN FACT.
.
CONGESTION MITIGATE AND ABOUT
RELIEF TO PINCH POINTS.
I I'M I'M TELLING I DRIVE IT ALL
THE TIME.
NORTH AND SOUTH
AND WHEN YOU WHEN YOU WERE
HEADING NORTH ON.
NINETY NINE FROM FRESNO TO
MADERA EITHER IN TWO LANES I
MEAN IT IS WALL TO WALL BACK UP
YOU GO THROUGH MADERA YOU GET
NORTH OF THERE. DON'T HELP TO
GET ON THE ON THE ON THE NORTH
SIDE AND INTO THE CHURCHILL AREA
THEN IT THEN IT'S OPENED UP.
A YOU GET INTO THE WIND AND AREA
THAT COMES DOWN TO TWO LANES AND
EVERYTHING IS BACKING UP.
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU'RE
APPROACHING ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
STOCKTON IN TO.
SACRAMENTO ITSELF IT'S DOWN TO
TWO THE TWO LANDS. NAM IT IS
DANGEROUS AND IT IS A OF AN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT HAS BEEN
WOEFULLY IGNORED. THAT IF THERE
IS ANY OF.
INFRASTRUCTURE PRIORITY OR
ACCELERATION THE CRIES OUT IT
SEEMS TO ME THIS IS.
THIS IS.
IS ONE WE ARE TO BE PAYING
ATTENTION TO
I LOOK FORWARD OPPORTUNITY.
OF REALLY DRILLING DOWN ON THIS
AND SEEING IF THERE ISN'T. SOME
MORE CLARITY WITH RESPECT TO HOW
SERIOUS IS THE STATE CALIFORNIA
GOING TO BE IN USING THESE THAT
INCREASED TAX REVENUES. TO DO
THE KINDS OF THINGS ON THE
NINETY NINE THAT HAVE BEEN.
SET ASIDE FOR SO SO LONG NOT
APPRECIATE THE RESPONSE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU. DOCTOR WEBER.
YES.
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE GOOD
THOUGH BUDGET A NEW SET SO. THAT
IS UPWARD. LOOKING ESPECIALLY
AFTER HAVING GONE THROUGH SOME
OF THE OTHER THINGS YOU. AND
DONE IN THE STATE SO IT'S GOOD
TO HAVE GOOD NEWS AND AND I
APPRECIATE THE GOOD NEWS WITH
CAUTION.
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW YOU STAND A
GOOD UP IN THE BLACK IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE WANT TO ACCOMPLISH. OF
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS.
YOU GAVE US A NUMBER FOUR.
.
FOR PER PUPIL SPENDING OF A
LITTLE OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND
ELEVEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED SOME
ODD DOLLARS IS THAT THE FOR THE
BASE GRANT OR IS THAT THE.
OTHER GRANTS THAT IT THERE AND
WHAT IS THE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
FOR SO. WHAT WILL BE BE LOOKING
AT IN TERMS OF THOSE SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE LOW INCOME FOSTER KID
SO FORTH AND SO ON WHAT'S THAT?
WAS IS THIS ELEVEN THOUSAND
INCLUDES EVERYBODY WAS A PARTIAL
SOME OF IT.
THE NUMBER I CITED ABOVE ROUGHLY
OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND IS JUST THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT PORTIONS OF
FEWER TO LOOK AT ALL FUNDING
SOURCES INCLUDING FEDERAL FUNDS
I THINK IT'S UPWARDS OF FOURTEEN
THOUSAND.
OKAY OKAY SO YOU'RE WILL SIXTEEN
THOUSAND MISTER BECAUSE I THINK
THOUSAND FOR SOME SCHOOLS. THAT
HAVE THE THOSE SOME CATEGORIES
SHOULD BE SEEING THAT THAT
AMOUNT BECAUSE I SAY THIS
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR HAS AS
GIVEN US A CHALLENGE I THINK IN
A STATEMENT ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY
FINALLY.
HE HAS A SAID WE NEED TO ASK
WHAT ARE PEOPLE DOING WITH THOSE
DOLLARS THAT ARE GOING TO THOSE
CHILDREN. AND WE ARE BEEN ASKING
THAT EVER SINCE WE START GIVEN
THE MONEY SO IT'S GOOD TO KNOW.
THAT WE NOW AS A BUDGET TO A
NEED TO TALK ABOUT NOT ONLY
FUNDING BUT ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE FUNDS THAT WE GIVE. A SOLD
THOSE SCHOOLS THAT WERE KIDS
OURS ARE LEAST LIKELY TO.
OR HAVE THE GREATEST CHALLENGES
I SHOULD SAY SHOULD BE LOOKING
AT A PROBLEM IN THE ADDITIONAL
FOUR TO FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER CHILD. IN THOSE SCHOOLS.
YEAH I'VE BEEN AVERAGE LET'S
READ THAT WOULD BE THE AVERAGE
OKAY SO I I HOPE MY SCHOOLS IN
LISTENING SO THAT THEY KNOW THAT
THEY WERE SCHOOLS THAT A POOR.
HAVE FOSTER KIDS THAT HAVE KIDS
AND LANGUAGE ISSUES THOSEKINDS
OF THINGS SHOULD BE SEEING ABOUT
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE PER
CHILD. TO PROVIDE THE KIND OF
FUNDING AND SUPPORT NECESSARY TO
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND THAT THAT'S A COULD THAT
THAT IS HELPFUL.
OKAY. LEASING RESIDENTS GET THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND WE CAN
GET BACK TO WHAT THOSE NUMBERS
BUT I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT VERY
MUCH SO BECAUSE. OF.
WE'VE ASKED THIS QUESTION
SEVERAL TIMES AND BUDGETS AND
WE'VE GOTTEN THE QUESTION OF
WHAT WE'RE NOT FULLY FUNDED WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW WOULD NOT
REALLY THERE THAT WE DON'T. KNOW
EXACTLY SO NOW THE WITH THEY
APPEAR.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO IDENTIFY THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THESE KIDS
SHOULD BE RECEIVING. AND WHAT
THAT MEANS FOR SCHOOLS IN TERMS
OF FUNDING AND HOPEFULLY CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP THAT'S THERE
SO I I APPRECIATE THAT.
THE OTHER THING.
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S SOMEONE
IS MENTIONED AS WITNESSED REPOSE
INCOMMUNICADO IT.
NOW TO MAKE IT YEAH ONLINE
COMPUTER COLLEGE AND I'M GONNA
HAVE MY COMMUNICATIVE BECAUSE
THEY ALL HAVE LOTS OF ONLINE
PROGRAMS.
AND SO I'M WONDERING WHAT WHAT
IS THE ADVANTAGE OF SETTING UP A
TOTALLY DIFFERENT BUREAUCRATIC
STRUCTURE. FULL ONLINE
INSTRUCTION AYE I. YOU KNOW
THAT'S THE ONLINE INSTRUCTION IS
PROBABLY THEY'RE PROBABLY MORE
OF A COMMUNICATIVE MAY NEVER SEE
ISSUES AND UC'S.
SO I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
IS THE RATIONALE BEHIND IT
SPECIALISMS ONLINE INSTRUCTION
JUST AS AN ENTITY HAS SAW MANY.
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF QUALITY
AND OUTCOME AND ASSURANCE OF
FOLKS THAT THINGS ARE HAPPENING
THAT SHOULD BE HAPPENING.
AND.
SOME I'M WONDERING WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE FOR THAT.
THANK YOU SO WE WANT TO
SPECIFICALLY TARGET THIS ONLINE
COLLEGE TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
REALLY ARE NOT BEING SERVED BY
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SEGMENTS
RIGHT NOW THERE'S TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION WORKING CALIFORNIANS.
WHO ARE WORKING FULL TIME THEY
HAVE CHILDREN AND THEY NEED MORE
FLEXIBILITY WHICH WE BELIEVE AN
ONLINE PLATFORM WILL PROVIDE FOR
THEM?
WERE ALSO PROPOSING THAT THERE
BE IN PERSON SUPPORTS WE'VE SEEN
THE RESEARCH ENOUGH COMPLETELY
ON ENVIRONMENT HAVE.
SOME CHALLENGES ALONG WITH IT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ATTENDING ONLINE
PROGRAMS OUT OF STATE FOR A COST
THAT'S MUCH HIGHER THAN WHAT WE
CAN PROVIDE TO OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
ARIZONA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
OTHER WESTERN GOVERNORS ARE
OFFERING THESE PROGRAMS TO
PEOPLE WITHIN CALIFORNIA SO WE'D
LIKE TO KEEP IT WITHIN THE KICK
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THEY'RE FAMILIAR WITH SERVING
THIS POPULATION OF STUDENTS AND
KEEP LOW COST.
IS THAT IT AND THAT'S AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND I'M I
SOMETIMES WONDER.
.
HAVING LIVED THROUGH A WHOLE
LOT DIFFERENT CYCLES OF OF HER
IT.
THAT SOMETIMES THE.
THE ISSUE IN ONLINE INSTRUCTION
THAT'S OUT OF STATE IS BECAUSE
OF ITS NOT THAT IS MORE
ACCESSIBLE IS THAT THEY'RE
PROBABLY THE FEWER DEMANDS MADE
ON THE INDIVIDUAL.
AND I'M WONDERING IF WE'RE
GOING TO COMPETE IS YOU CAN
COMPETE TO THE POINT THAT YOU
GET TO THE LOWEST LEVEL. OF
PERFORMANCE OR ACHIEVEMENT
EQUALITY AND SIMPLY FOR THE SAKE
OF COMPETING.
RATHER THAN BECAUSE THEY ARE
AND I SAY THIS IN BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY ONLINE COURSES
THERE'S SO MANY NOT ONLY.
THE OF THE PRIVATE ONES BUT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF ONLINE
COURSES AND I PROBABLY HAVEN'T
HAD A PERSON'S WORK FOR ME WAS
NOT TAKEN AN ONLINE COURSE.
ALTHOUGH THE COMMUTER COLLEGES
OF BUT I DO KNOW THAT OF THE
OTHER PLACES THAT ARE MORE
EXPENSIVE OFTEN MARKET
THEMSELVES. AS NOT HAVING TO DO
A WHOLE LOT OR THEY'LL COUNT ALL
THE. YOUR WORK LIFE AND YOU THIS
NEED THAT TOWARD THE CREDIT OF
OF ONE CHEATING SOMETHING SO I'M
HOPING THAT WE DON'T GET INTO
THE COMPETITIVE THING. AND
DISCOVER THAT IT MAY NOT BE
ACCESSIBILITY AND MAYBE
SOMETHING ELSE AND THEN WE FIND
OURSELVES. ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
WHO CAN GO TO THE LOWEST RUNG
THOUGH OF PERFORMANCE AND
ACHIEVEMENT. OF SO I HAVE TO I
HOPE WE LOOK AT THAT CAREFULLY.
IF WE TALK ABOUT FUNDING OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AT A HIGHER
LEVEL TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
COURSES THAT ONLINE. A THAT'S
ONE THING BUT A SIMPLE
BUREAUCRATIC STRUCTURE THIS
STRICTLY ONLINE ABOUT IT HAS
SOME CONCERNS ME.
YOU HAVE ALL YOU'VE YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF LOW OF
DOLLARS FOR ALL INFRASTRUCTURE
IN WORK ON.
HAVE YOU PRIORITIZE IT WITH
REGARDS TO WHAT PRISONS IF WE
WERE TO START CLOSING PRISONS
WHAT PRISONS WOULD PROBABLY BE
ON THE FIRST LEVEL FOR CLOSING
SO THAT WE DON'T END UP DOING
GREAT REPAIRS.
IN THAT I KNOW THE FANS ARE
NOTORIOUS FOR DOING THAT OF A
BILL TO HOLD OUT OF ONE OF THE
STUFF IN SAN DIEGO MCI DE THEN
SHUT IT DOWN TO HIT. THEATERS IN
HOSPITAL PEOPLE NEVER DONE
ANYTHING IN BUT THEY WERE BRAND
NEW BECAUSE THEY WANT A LIST FOR
REPAIR AND THEY MAKE SHUTDOWNS
ALL THOSE REPAIRS OF JUST. A
WONDERFUL FOR THE COMMUNITY PLAY
WOULD BUT UMMM DID VERY LITTLE
IN TERMS OF FEDERAL BUDGET SO.
I HAVE WE DO WE HAVE A DO WE
HAVE ANY IDEA OF OF THE
PRIORITIZING THOSE REPAIRS TO
THAT POINT THE ON MY COLLEGE
WILL BE CREDITED. AND IT WILL BE
HELD TO ALL THE SAME
ACCOUNTABILITY STANDARDS IS ANY
BRICKS AND MORTAR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE
SO OBVIOUSLY OUR TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ISN'T OUT QUITE YET BUT
WHEN ITS OUT YOU'LL SEE SOME OF
THOSE COMPONENTS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT
CONVERSATION AT SOMETHING WE
WEIGHED VERY. HEAVILY AS WE PROP
FORWARD THIS PROPOSAL DEBATED
AT.
MOVING ON TO CDC ARE.
THIS IS OUR SECOND YEAR OF
PROPOSAL I'VE FOR ROOF REPAIRS
FOR CORRECTIONS I'M OBVIOUSLY
AFTER WE GOT OUT THE DROUGHT AND
WE INTERVIEWED THE RAINY SEASON
AND AND WE HAD SOME VERY
PRONOUNCED PROBLEMS ON OUR
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES. AND ON
THE ROOF REPAIRS REALLY CAUSING
DELAYS AND PROGRAMMING AND MANY
OTHER IMPORTANT ASPECTS.
INSTEAD THIS IS THE SECOND YEAR
THAT WE'VE WORKED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT PRIORITIZING THE
PROJECTS ON MOST IN NEED. WHAT
YOUR POINT WE DO HAVE ON A PLAN?
FOR AYE OUT OF STATE THAT MY
COLLEAGUE GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL ON THAT.
CLINT COUNT APARTMENT A FINANCE
SO.
DEFINITELY WE LOOKED AT PRISONS
THAT WE ARE NOT LIKELY TO CLOSE
IN THE FUTURE BUT TECH HEAVENLY
IN THAT FRAMEWORK OUT I WOULD
SAY THAT. WE'RE UNDER A
CONSTRAINT IN THE PRISON SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE A POPULATION CAP
THAT WE HAVE TO MAINTAIN
COMPLIANCE WITH.
THAT'S AT ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND THERE'S A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT WAYS TO COUNT OUT BUT
I WON'T GET INTO THAT NOW. DATE
CURRENT INMATE POPULATIONS AT
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND
WE THINK POPULATION THERE
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN'S GONNA
REDUCE THE INMATE POPULATION. BY
ABOUT ELEVEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED INMATES.
I AM BY TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO
EVEN IF YOU GET TO THAT PERIOD
OF TIME WE'RE STILL IN THOUSANDS
OF CONTRACT BEDS THAT WE.
ON THAT ARE OPERATED BY CCR SO
WE'RE REALLY JUST FINDING OUR
EXISTING OWNED AND OPERATED
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WERE BUILT
MANY YEARS AGO AND.
IN DEBT DESPERATE NEED OF THESE.
IMPROVEMENTS SO THAT THAT SORT
OF THE LANDS WERE LOOKING OUT ON
MAKING THESE AND THE STRAIGHT
REPAIRS.
ARE WE LOOKING AT ENDING OUR
HOUSE STATE CONTRACTS ANYTIME
SOON.
YES THE BUDGET OUT PLANS TO GET
FULLY OUT OF ALL OF OUR ARTISTIC
CONTRACT BEDS IN EARLY NINETEEN
TWENTY.
THANK YOU.
THIS IS A FELLOW PUTS A CONTRACT
FIGURE FOR THE NUMBER OF PLANTS.
A NUMBER OF BAD OR CURLY
CONTRACTING OUT SO WHERE IN
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND OUT OF STATE
BADS IN ABOUT FORTY TWO HUNDRED
IN STATE BADS WE ALSO LISA
FACILITY THAT'S OPERATED BY THE
STATE AND THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED BEDS.
DOCTOR TOWARD YOUR FOLLOW UP.
OKAY DID YOU.
I GOT ON THE LIST. OKAY MISTER
MATHIS.
SO BUT I'D LIKE TO GO BACK TO.
NUMBER FONG SCUM IT'S ALONG
WITH.
MEMBER PATTERSON'S
AND IN SEVERAL OF US HAVE
BROUGHT UP.
THAT THE CITY  MONDAY AND
NOT SEATS YOU BUT THEY ARE.
SEE INTO MONEY AND FOR SCURRY.
THE FIRES THE THE CLEAN UP.
AND MY BIGGEST QUESTION I THINK
HERE IS WHAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THIS WHO WE'VE GONE FROM.
DAD FORESTRY.
MANAGEMENT.
TO INCREASED FIRES.
TO.
HISTORIC MUDSLIDES.
TO. THE COST OF FLOODS.
TWO INCREASED ROAD COST.
TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER
PROBLEMS.
AND ALL OF THESE.
WELCOME BACK TO ONE THING.
AND IT'S.
IT'S BEEN SAID OVER AND OVER.
BUT WE'RE NOT TAKING CARE THE
FOREST THE IT'S AN ALL STARTS
RIGHT THERE.
IN SO.
WATER THE ANALYTICS.
I CHAU THAT IF WE ACTUALLY SPEND
SOME MORE MONEY. TAKING CARE THE
FORCE WITH WITH.
BEST PRACTICES FROM FORESTERS
WHO UNDERSTAND THIS THE BEST.
WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY SAVE SOME
MORE MONEY ON THE OTHER END?
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO PAY FOR
MORE CLEAN DRINKING WATER IN
CLEANING UP GIANT MUD SLIDES AND
WIPED OUT ENTIRE AREAS IN KILL
PEOPLE AND THESE HORRIBLE FOR.
WORST FIRES WE CAN ACTUALLY GO
DO THE RIGHT THING ON ONE END.
AND TAKE CARE THE PROBLEM UP
FRONT.
STATE OF SPENDING MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
ON THE BACK IN BECAUSE WE CAN DO
THE RIGHT THING IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
SO NOW WE'VE GONE THROUGH THIS
YEAR WE'VE HAD MASSIVE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES CATASTROPHIC.
FLOODS MUD SLIDES
THE WHOLE MIND LOSS OF LIFE.
ALL BECAUSE WE SIMPLY DIDN'T
SPEND THE MONEY.
YEAH AT THE FRONT END OF THE
FOREST.
THE IN LISTEN TO THE FORRESTERS
IN AND GET A RIGHT THERE.
SO WHY THEY ARE THEIR ANALYTICS
DON THAT SHOW HIM MAYBE IF WE
ACTUALLY SPEND THAT THE MONEY TO
DO THIS UP HERE.
WE WERE ALL.
PAY OUT HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
LATER.
WHAT ONE THING THAT I THINK IS
HELPFUL TO TO THINK ABOUT AND
THAT'S JUST MY FIRST?
OKAY A ONE THING THAT'S HELPFUL
TO THINK ABOUT IS AS PART OF CAP
AND TRADE LAST YEAR WE HAD THE
STATE RESPONSE RESPONSIBILITY
AREA AND WE.
WE STOPPED THAT FEET BUT. AS
FAR AS SKILL IN SCOPE IT WAS
ABOUT AN EIGHTY MILLION DOLLAR
AND PROGRAM AND SO IN ADDITION
TO BACK FEELING THAT FEED THE
CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE PLAN
INCLUDED TWO HUNDRED MILLION. OF
FOR ACTIVITIES THAT ARE VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT WAS DONE WITH IN
THE* R. RAY FOR FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
EXAGGERATE. ADDITIONALLY WE HAD
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
CAL LOW WE ASK FOR OUR MUTUAL
AID LOCAL MUTUAL AID.
SO WE HAVE PUT IN THE CURRENT
YEAR SIGNIFICANT NEW RESOURCES
IN FORCE MANAGEMENT AND ADDITION
TO SOME OF THE BASELINE BUDGET
ADJUSTMENTS THAT WE'VE MADE FOR
CAL FIRE AND OTHER ENTITIES.
I THINK IT'S BEEN MENTIONED
OBVIOUSLY TRUE IMMORTALITY IS.
UNPRECEDENTED THAT SCALE AND
SCOPE I ACTUALLY THINK IT'S
UPWARDS OF A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION A DEAD AND DYING TREES.
AND SO OUR HOPE IS OBVIOUSLY
THIS INFUSION OF HIGH.
ADDITIONAL GTR OFF MONEY WILL
HELP US DEAL WITH THIS
UNPRECEDENTED DISASTER AND ARE
FORCED.
WHERE WHERE IS THAT FUNDING
ACTUALLY GOING WITHIN THOSE
BUDGET
BECAUSE OF ITS IT'S ONE THING TO
SAY WE'RE GONNA OF HE CALIPHATE
OR? OR OR PUT IN ONE AREA BUT
IT'S A WHOLE OTHER TO SAY THEM
LAYS ACTUALLY GONNA BE
INTERJECTED INTO CREATING FOR
THREE CONTRACTS TO DO FORESTRY.
DID INVEST PRACTICES IN FORESTRY
VERSUS SOMETHING ELSE
HE'S I THINK EVERYBODY WOULD
AGREE THAT THAT'S WHERE THE KEY
PROBLEM IS THAT'S BECAUSE THEN.
BECAUSE LIFE IN LAND DOWN THE
ROAD.
THE.
GTR UP FUNDS THE OVER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ARE ALLOCATED TO
CAL FIRE BUT THE DECISIONS ARE
MADE REGIONALLY WITH CAL FIRE
STAFF OBVIOUSLY SOME OF THE
ISSUES THROUGHOUT OUR FORCES
HAVE AS LIKE DIFFERENCES
REGIONALLY. SO IT REALLY IS A
LOCAL BASED OUR DECISION MAKING
PROCESS AND THEY ARE GRANTS.
ON THAT GO OUT.
ADDITIONALLY IN PREVIOUS YEARS
WE'VE INCLUDED A LOCAL
ASSISTANCE MONEY FOR TREE
REMOVAL AYE AND RULE COUNTIES
OBVIOUSLY THE HIGH COST ACTUALLY
TO REMOVE SOME OF THESE DEAD AND
DYING TREES ESPECIALLY FOR.
COUNTIES BEYOND FOR HOMEOWNERS
FRANKLY ON THE THAT WE HAVE HOT
PROPOSALS AND TO HELP OFFSET
THAT COST IS ONE THE PAST.
SO BACK THE REPRESSION OTHER
ANALYTICS THE SHOW THE COST
SAVINGS.
STEVEN BENSON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AYE I DON'T YOU CAN
ANSWER JUST YES OR NO YEAH I I
DON'T THINK THERE'S GREAT
ANALYTICS TO HAND OVER TO SAY
HERE THIS THIS IS THE KIND A.
OF THE.
THE PAYOFF OF THE AND DOLLARS
HERE IN THE FUTURE THAT I THINK
WE ARE NOW IS NOT GREAT
ANALYTICS.
AWESOME.
I ANALYTICS WERE TRYING TO
CONTEMPLATE MORE SINCE IT'S
COMING FROM GIGI ARE ASKED.
IS.
THE REDUCTION OF POTENTIAL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
AND SO THAT THAT'S SOME OF THE
INTERNAL DISCUSSION WE'VE BEEN
HAVING ON TO MEASURE THE
OVERALL.
.
IMPACT THAT COULD FORCE
MANAGEMENT HOUSE ON REDUCING
FUTURE ADMISSION.
LA JOH GOES HAVE ANYTHING NOT
NOTHING THAT RIGHT NOW BUT WE
CAN CERTAINLY LOOK INTO IT OKAY.
GOOD FOR AND I THINK.
WALTER SHOULD JUST REAL QUICK
BACK TO WELL WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON TO SAY WITH THE
NINETY NINE TRADE QUARTER.
.
THE IT STILL BEYOND ME THAT.
THE LARGEST AGRICULTURAL AREA IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD AND IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY. THAT'S
PRODUCING.
NEARLY SEVEN BILLION GDP WAY
WHICH IS DOUBLE ANY OTHER STATE
THE NATION.
IS ON THAT CORRIDOR WE GET.
AS THE STATE WE STILL HAVE AN.
MAY THAT QUARTER ACTUAL CORRIDOR
AND WE STILL HAVE THESE PINCH
POINTS THAT ARE TWO LANES.
I MEAN IT'S THE YOU CAN SAY
IT'S.
A WE DECIDE THESE THINGS OVER
HERE BOYD.
THAT'S WHERE RELIGIOUS FOOD
COMES FROM IN HERE.
THE STATE HASN'T DONE ANYTHING
TO HELP MOVE.
ANY OF THAT NAY IN INCREASED
LENGTH CAPACITY THEIR WORDS.
VERY VERY NEEDED IN IT'S BEEN
SAID FOR THE LAST DECADE ON HOW
NEEDED THAT IS. AND WHEN YOU
TACK GAINING YOU SAY THERE'S
PROJECTS THAT ARE GONNA TAKE
FIVE SIX YEARS.
WE SIT HERE WE GET THESE OUR
POPULATION PROJECTION NUMBERS
WHERE WE TALK ABOUT THE STATE TO
TWENTY MILLION PEOPLE NOW.
IN BY TWENTY THIRTY WE'RE GONNA
BE A THIRTY MILLION BY TWENTY
FIFTY WERE GONNA BE AT EIGHTY
MILLION.
AND.
THE FACT IS AND IN WHAT ALONG
WITH THOSE NUMBERS WE GET. SIXTY
FIVE PERCENT OF THAT GROWTH IS
GOING TO GO TO THE SOUTHERN SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY.
WHICH IS THAT NINETY NINE TRADE
CORRIDOR.
SO IT'S GONNA TAKE ALL THESE
YEARS TO BUILD IT.
IN THAT'S THE POPULATION
PROJECTION.
THEN WE NEED TO GET WITH THE
PROGRAM AND START ACTUALLY
CALCULATING SOME OF THAT
POPULATION PROJECTION OF THOSE
NUMBERS.
SO IS THERE ANYTHING BEING DONE
ON THAT OR WE JUST LOOKING AT
WHAT WE NEEDED TEN YEARS AGO AND
WE'RE STILL NOT CATCHING UP.
THE SP ONE FUNDING EVERY WEEK
WE'VE BEEN IN A SITUATION WHERE
THE AVAILABLE FUNDING FOR.
.
ANYHOW WE REPAIRS HAS BEEN
DECLINING OVER THE LAST YOU
MULTIPLE YEARS LIBS LONG AS I'VE
BEEN ON THE PHONE FOR AT LEAST
LAST TEN YEARS.
AND.
YOUNG TWO GIVEN THE OF THE FACT
THAT IT'S A IT'S A PER GALLON
YOU WE COLLECT EIGHTEEN CENTS A
GALLON. PER GALLON IN THE GAS
MILEAGE IS BEEN GOING UP SO EVEN
WITH ADDITIONAL VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED ADDITIONAL POPULATION.
THE NET DOLLARS HAVE BEEN GOING
DOWN SO WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT A
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE HAD
ENOUGH MONEY TO DO ALL OF THE
PRIORITIES.
NO.
S. B. ONENESS HAS GIVEN US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK FORWARD TO
LOOK IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS AND.
ADDRESS THESE DIFFERENT AREAS
OF PLACES LIKE HIGHWAY NINETY
NINE IS A VERY IMPORTANT TRADE
CORRIDORS VERY IMPORTANT JUST
CONGESTED CORRIDOR FOR PEOPLE
TRAVEL.
.
YEAH WE WERE WERE EXPANDING THE
CAPACITY AS WE SPEAK I BELIEVE
CDCS LOOKING AT ADDING A BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL PROJECTS
JUST IN APRIL. ONTO THIS OF THE.
.
TO THE STATE REHABILITATION
PROGRAM THE CAPITAL PROGRAM. AND
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE WILL
CONTINUE TO TO DEVELOP THAT I
SENATE THAT THE.
THAT.
NEXT FOUR YEAR OF REHABILITATION
PROGRAM WILL HAVE.
ADDITIONAL TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN CAPACITY SO THAT'S
THAT'S A HUGE INCREASE OVER. A
TOTAL CAPACITY BEFORE A IN THE
FOUR YEARS OF OF SOMEWHERE
AROUND TEN BILLION SO THIS IS
JUST OVER ABOVE THAT.
SO DOES THE.
PROGRESS IS GOING TO BE THERE
PROXIMAL FORWARD AND.
GET OF THE IT THERE'S GET WE
HAVE.
INSPECTOR GENERAL THAT MAKE
SURE THAT.
YOU WERE GETTING THE RESULTS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR AND.
YOU KNOW AND THAT'S STATEWIDE.
WITH THE SP ONE WEBSITE THAT
THAT'S ODDITIES THAT HAS IT MUCH
EASIER TO THE QUESTION.
YOU KNOW THE RESULTS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR WHAT ARE THE RESULTS
OVERLY FOR BECAUSE RIGHT WHAT WE
HAVE HERE YOU SAID IT EARLIER.
MEMBER
WE GO ALONG AND WE'RE FIXING THE
ROADS WERE ALSO LOOKING TO
EXPAND THAT WE WON'T HAVE TO
TOUCH IT WANTS.
WHICH GETS INTO.
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHEN YOU GET INTO
THE GF SIDE AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
SO IF THE GOAL IS YOU ONLY HIT
THAT PIECE THE HIGHWAY WANTS AND
ONLY HIT ONE OF THAT IS THE GOAL
THE GOAL BECAUSE THAT NEVER NOW
BECAUSE OR WHAT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN.
IS WHICH MANY PEOPLE'S TAXPAYER
DOLLARS.
TO GO FIX A POTHOLE.
AND A YEAR LATER COME BACK.
IN FIX AN OVERPASS IN THE NEW
YEAR LATER COME BACK AND TEAR
DOWN THE OVER PASS BILL IN WHITE
KNIT DO THAT'S.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY IF WE IF WE
CAN IDENTIFY THAT THOSE TYPE OF
PROJECTS CAN BE DONE IN SYNERGY
WE WANT TO DO THOSE PROJECTS AND
SYNERGY AND TRY TO HAVE AS.
AS COMPREHENSIVE A PROJECTS AS
POSSIBLE.
IN THE PAST WE HAVE HAD THE
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO BE ABLE TO
COMPLETE THAT TYPE OF CONFERENCE
OF PROJECTS WE HAVE THAT NOW.
YOU KNOW AS FAR AS THE GOALS
WERE LOOKING FOR S. B. ONE HAS.
OF FOR SPECIFIC METRICS THAT
ARE.
HIGHWAY RELATED.
AND YOU KNOW THE THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL THE FOCUSING ON THIS FOR
BUT CALTRANS HAS A WHOLE HAS.
A MYRIAD OF WHAT THEY CALL
LEVEL OF SERVICE RELATED.
BUT ACHIEVEMENTS AND THEY'RE
LOOKING TO ACHIEVING IT YEAH
THAT INVOLVES.
MANY DIFFERENT METRICS SAFETY
METRICS.
CONGESTION METRIC SMOOTHNESS.
ALSO SO THERE THE.
ME OTHER CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD THAT.
YOU KNOW WE'VE ONLY AT THIS
POINT SB ONE IS ONLY GOING TO
AFFECT IT THE NEW RATES APPOINT
IN EFFECT SINCE NOVEMBER FIRST.
AND.
BECAUSE OF THE MECHANISM FOR
COLLECTING YOU KNOW THE
MECHANISMS BEEN IN PLACE THAT
IT'S A CONTINUING MY CAN OF
REFLECTING SALES TAX WE REALLY
NOT WE HAVEN'T STARTED TO SEE
AND WE WON'T START SEEING TOLL
SENSUALLY THIS. THIS MONTH'S
DISTRIBUTION OF GAS TAX REVENUE.
THE THE NEW S. B. ONE REVENUE
WILL START COMING INTO PLAY NOW
BECAUSE OF THAT SO. YOU KNOW A
LOT OF THINGS WE'VE DONE SO FAR
AS FAR AS XCELERATED PROJECTS
ARE. AN ATTEMPT TO DO THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO THAT WERE ALREADY
IN THE PIPE ARE IN THE PLANNING
BUT YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO TO. BACK FILL THAT
WITH NEW PROJECTS WELL THERE'S
THERE'S TWO THINGS I'M HOPING
YOU'RE COUNTING IN THE MATRIX
AND THAT'S THE POPULATION
GROWTH.
AND ALSO THE FACT THAT THE THE
FUTURISTS WOULD TELL US THAT IN
TEN YEARS FROM NOW EVERYBODY
WILL BE
DRIVING BATTERY OPERATED THOMAS
VEHICLE SAUCE BICU ONE WILL BE
POINTLESS.
SO I HOPE YOU GOT HER CAN.
INCLUDING THAT IF I MAY WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A DEMOGRAPHICS
CHAPTER WHICH ENCOURAGE EVERYONE
TO READ IN OUR SUMMARY AND IT
ACTUALLY HAS US. ONLY SLIGHTLY
HIGHER THE NATIONAL POPULATION
GROWTH CALIFORNIA'S ACTUALLY NOT
GROWING AS IT ONCE DID AND WE
EXPECT THE NEXT DOUBLING OF THE
POPULATION TO TAKE PLACE IN
EIGHTY FIVE YEARS.
SO THAT WE ARE POPULOUS STATE
THERE'S A COUPLE DIFFERENT.
DEMOGRAPHIC TRENDS THAT ARE
DRIVING A LITTLE BIT SLOWING OF
THE POPULATION.
THANK YOU.
WE WILL GO ATTACHED TO THE
MYSTERY AT ALL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR AYE
PRESENTATIONS.
I HAVE A.
I HAVE A QUESTION NOW JUST A
COUPLE QUESTIONS AND I'LL TRY
AND MAKE THEM BRIEF BECAUSE I
KNOW TIME IS GETTING LONGER.
A WITH REGARD TO A CAGE FULL
FUNDING OF THE C. T. PROGRAM AND
OTHERS.
A PROPOSED TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO BE ALLOCATED FOR CT
FUNDING WHICH I THINK IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT.
APPARENTLY TEACHER THAT'S
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE FOR SURE.
.
WHERE I STRUGGLE WITH THIS
PROPOSAL IS PUTTING THAT MONEY
NIGHT YOU PROBABLY KNOW WHERE
I'M GOING IS IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE?
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE I GUESS AND
WHY WOULD WE DO THAT WHAT
EXPERTISE TO THEY HAPPENED IS
OUR PRECEDENT FOR. FOR
ALLOCATING QUE TWELVE MONEY TO
ANOTHER BODY AND THEN SAY WELL
IN THERE AND AND OTHERS
BACK TO THE K. TWELVE BODY AND
THEN WHAT EXPERTISE TO THEY HAVE
CENTER. WEISS IS A GOOD IDEA.
UP CERTAINLY I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION ONE PART OF
THE.
PIECES ACTUALLY PAY FOR A KEY
TWELVE NAVIGATORS OF SOMEBODY
SPECIFICALLY.
WITHIN THE K. TWELVE COMMUNITY
TO HELP.
IMPLEMENT THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM I THINK PART OF WHAT WE
WANTED TO DO WAS TO TAKE.
THE CT  MONEY OUT OF THE
SITE WELL I'VE JUST K. TWELVE.
AND BROADEN IT TO INCLUDE
FEDERAL WE OWE WHAT DOLLARS AS
WELL AS WHAT WE'VE PROVIDED TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE REALLY DO NEED A REGIONAL
WORKFORCE APPROACH AND OUR HOPE
IS TO INCLUDE K. TWELVE AND THAT
DISCUSSION SO THAT ANY CT
PROGRAMS OFFERED WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH A COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR A
KEY TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICT. ARE
REALLY ALIGNED TO THE WORKFORCE
NEEDS THAT WE NOW WERE HAPPENING
IN THAT REGION. AND IT ALLOWS
THIS CONVERSATION TO HAVE IT
HAPPEN IN CONCERT WITH INDUSTRY
LEADERS WHICH WE THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
WE THANK YOU I'M I DON'T KNOW
THAT'S REAL CONVINCING TO ME BUT
I KNOW WE
WE'LL HAVE TIME TO DISCUSS THIS
THE NAVIGATOR PROTA. I JUST
DON'T KNOW HOW THAT EXPERTISE IS
NECESSARILY YOUR HOUSE TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL WILL
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION AT ON THE
LINE.
SO THANK YOU.
AND MAYBE THIS QUESTIONS FOR
MISTER TAYLOR WITH REGARD TO THE
SURPLUS.
WAS GREAT THAT WE HAVE A
SURPLUS I'D ACTUALLY LIKE TO SEE
IT MORE THAN THE GOVERNOR WOULD
QUITE FRANKLY MYSELF.
BECAUSE I WAS NOT A CITY COUNCIL
OR I LAID OFF A LOT OF PEOPLE
HUNDREDS.
RIGHT I'VE SEEN THE BAD TIMES
AND I KNOW WHAT THAT FEELS LIKE
TO LOOK IN SOMEONE'S. FACE AND I
CAN'T HELP YOU WE HAVE TO DO WE
HAVE TO DO FOR THE BUDGET
HEALTH.
OF THE ENTITY AM ELECTED TO
REPRESENT. SO.
I AM. PRETTY FISCALLY PRUDENT
AND.
BUT WITH REGARD TO THIS MONEY
THAT WHETHER. YOU I DON'T THEM
OUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
SETTING ASIDE IT DOESN'T MATTER
REALLY AS MUCH AS.
DO YOU HAVE AN OPINION.
OR RECOMMENDATION WITH REGARD TO
WHERE THAT'S MONEY PUT SHOULD BE
PUT RESERVE SHOULD PAY DOWN.
IS IT BETTER OFF MAYBE TO PAY
DOWN DEBT BECAUSE YOU MAKE IT A
THREE TO ONE RATIO IN THE OUT
YEARS. CAN YOU JUST EXTRAPOLATE
ON THAT A BIT SURE AGAIN IT'S
SORT OF BALANCING THESE
DIFFERENT NEEDS.
IF YOU WANNA HAVE A BIGGER
RESERVE YOU CAN BE CAUTIOUS
ABOUT MAKING THAT OPTIONAL
PAYMENT YOU CAN CONSIDER OTHER
WAYS THAT MAYBE YOU CAN.
ACHIEVE THOSE THAT SAME IMPACT
OF A RESERVE FOR EXAMPLE YOU CAN
PUT MONEY IN YOUR DISCRETION
RESERVE YOU COULD. PREPAY SOME
CALPERS COST.
OF THERE'S OTHER THINGS YOU
COULD DO TO PREPARE YOURSELF
OTHER THAN JUST THE BSA IN THE
THE SFU.
NOW YOU'RE ASKING THE QUESTION
AS SORT OF AN ALTERNATIVE TO
BUILDING UP THE RESERVE OTHER
OTHER SMART THINGS THAT WE COULD
DO WITH THE MONEY SUCH AS.
PAYING OFF SOME THOSE DEBTS YET
THAT'S THAT'S AND ALSO A SMART
THING TO DO.
YOU GET THE RETURN AT THIS
SEVEN PERCENT AND YOU KNOW YOU
PAY OFF THESE DEBTS FASTER THAT
ALSO PUTS YOU IN A BETTER
POSITION DOWN THE ROAD.
IT'S JUST HARD TO KNOW HOW TO
HOW TO BALANCE THOSE.
THERE'S NO RIGHT ANSWER I THINK
TO QUESTION.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
APPROACH.
IN YOU YOU CONSTANTLY REMIND A
LEGISLATURE THAT WERE.
YEAH A DAY CLOSER TO THE NEXT
RECESSION.
AND.
TOUGH TIMES ARE COMING SOON
WITH THE MORE WE PREPARED TODAY
THE BETTER OFF WE SO APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
AND AND THANK YOU BOMB.
SO AYE X. SOUGHT YOU HAD A
GRAPHIC.
UP THERE THAT WE'VE WE'VE HAD
SAID IT STEADY GROWTH.
I GUESS IT TOOK TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
YEAR WE'VE VETS SURPLUSES.
THEN I JUST WENT.
IS THAT ABOUT ACCURATE.
CALIFORNIA FIRST CHARTS.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THE LAST
TIME BUT LET ME LOOK LIKE FIRST
CHART THE LAST HER ACTUALLY
SHOWS OUT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN JANUARY WHAT WE'RE
PROJECTING FOR BALANCE VERSUS
DEFICIT.
ON THAT WAS THAT THE BLACK BARS
IN THE RED BARS ON THE CHARGES
THAT THE CHART YOU'RE REFERRING
TO I SAW A CHART THAT SHOWS.
THAT SAID FOR CERTAIN TIME.
WE'VE HAD SURPLUSES.
IN THE BUDGET.
WE'RE GONNA START JUST PUT
COMPETE COULD CAN LOOK AT THAT
CHART BACK UP.
THIS WAS THE ONE I WAS
REFERENCING BUT I DON'T THAT I
DON'T THINK GROUND FUNDS.
WE HAVE A RECESSION SCENARIO
CHARRING.
OR WILL IT PROP NINETY EIGHT.
NO SCHOOL FOR.
I THINK THAT'S IT BAT.
AND.
THIS IS ACTUALLY OUR RECESSION
SONORA RIGHT BUT YOU YOU SHOWED.
BIG IS THE YELLOW LINE.
THE INCREASE IN THE BUDGET WAS
THAT BECAUSE OF THE SURPLUS AND
WE HAD A SURPLUS SINCE THAT
TIME.
WE HAVE A SURPLUS RIGHT NOW AND
THAT'S OUR FORECAST CHINESE
AGAIN.
WE'VE BEEN HAVING STEADY
SURPLUSES SINCE WHEN WE'VE IT I
KNOW WE HAD RECESSION.
WE'VE HAD A STEADY SURPLUS.
LET ME DO IT ANOTHER WAY.
I GOT ELECTED IN TWENTY TWELVE.
EVERY YEAR
IT'S MY COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE
BEEN ELECTED IN TWENTY TWO YEAR
TWENTY TWELVE.
ONE.
MOST OF US ALL OF US GOT TWELVE
YEARS INSTEAD OF SIX.
WE'VE HAD A STEADY
S. AUTOMATICALLY THAT.
SURPLUS IS THAT RIGHT OR WRONG.
COURTESY OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THAT'S CORRECT SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE.
THIS SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET
WAS THE FIRST HOUR WE HAD TO
LOOK FOR IS THE SOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU.
NO I.
I WOULDN'T SAY SOMETHING ELSE
BUT.
SINCE THAT TIME I KNOW WE'VE WE
MAKING SOME PRUDENT DECISION
SINCE THEN.
TO TO ENSURE FOR THE NEXT.
FOR THE NEXT SHORTFALL A
RECESSION.
I WAS GONNA GO THERE AND SAY
SINCE I'VE BEEN ELECTED WE HAD
NOTHING BUT GOOD BUDGET BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT JUST ME.
.
BUT THE POINT I'M TRYING TO MAKE
HERE IS.
I KNOW WE'RE EXPECTING GLOOM AND
DOOM.
BUT I I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
RIGHT LET'S NOT.
MISTAKEN IN THIS IS IS THE FACT
THAT.
WE'VE HAD STEADY INCREASES AND
AS SOME MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
POINTED OUT.
WE'RE LOOKING AT PRUDENT WAYS TO
BECOME IS RECESSION PROOF AS
POSSIBLE WHETHER IT'S PAYING OFF
THE DEBT. RAINY DAY FUND THAT WE
ARE.
ACTUALLY TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING
THAT WE CAN WHAT DID THE NEW
TWELVE YEAR MEMBERS.
BECAUSE IT IS MORE LIKELY WE
WILL BE HERE.
DURING THAT TIME IF IT EVER
COMES WHEN IT COMES
AND THAT.
WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING WE CAN.
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAD WE YOU
USED TO TAXPAYERS MONEY.
GOV PRUDENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY AS
BEST WE CAN WITH THE INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT MAY SOUND MORE
STATEMENTS ONLY YOU CAN ANSWER
BUT. I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE
GOT THAT OUT THERE.
TO.
I'VE HAD I'VE DONE AUDITS.
WHERE WE CAN LOOK AT? THE WAY
WE SPEND.
THE TAXPAYERS MONEY.
AND HOPEFULLY SOME THESE AUDITS
THAT. WE'VE DONE HAVE BEEN
HELPFUL IN YOU DEVELOPING THE
BUDGET I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
CRITICISM. OR DISCUSSION ABOUT
US HAVING MORE HEARINGS ON HOW
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT WE SPEND
THE MONEY.
THE MONIES THAT WE HAVE NOT
GIVEN IT ONE EXAMPLE. I AM. I'VE
I'VE MET I'VE OF ASSEMBLY
INVOLVED WITH PUBLIC SAFETY
CHAIR PUBLIC SAFETY ALSO. BUDGET
PUBLIC SAFETY.
I'M REALLY CONCERNED ESPECIALLY
AFTER TALKING WITH THEM.
CDC SEE OUR. ANNA CCPOA IN A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ABOUT HOW
EFFECTIVE
THE REHABILITATION PROGRAMS.
THERE WE HAVE BOTH INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE OF CDC ARE HOW EFFECTIVE
THEY REALLY ARE NOT PLANTED.
TO S. AN AUDIT OF ALL CDC OUR
PROGRAMS.
BECAUSE IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET IS
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS I
THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING FOR GRANTS FOR
REHABILITATION.
THIS IS REALLY GREAT THAT WE'RE
PUTTING MONEY TOWARDS THAT BUT I
THINK WHAT WE NEED TO BE.
FOCUSED ON EVEN MORE SO IS HOW
EFFECTIVE
AS MY. COLLEAGUE FROM ELK GROVE
LIKES TO SAY.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE PROGRAMS IN CDC
ARE LIKE ROCK CLIMBING.
I DON'T OF ROCK CLIMBING.
IS AN EFFECTIVE USE OF THE WAY
WE NEED TO USE THE MONEY.
AND QUITE FRANKLY I'M JUST NOT
CRITICISM ON IF THERE IS A ROCK
FRANK CLIMBING CLASSES SINCE IN.
AND OUR CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
I'M NOT CRITICIZING IT I JUST
WANT TO KNOW. WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE EFFECTIVE.
AND THEY DO HELP TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM
BECAUSE ON THE BACK END AS WE
START TALKING ABOUT HOW
EFFECTIVELY WE UTILIZE. OUR OUR
PRISONS WHETHER WE CLOSE THEM.
OR WHETHER WE
TRANSFER THEM TO BECOME MEDICAL
FACILITIES INSTEAD OF CLOSING
THEM OR.
OR REHABILITATION FACILITIES
STEAD OF CLOSING THEM.
WHEN WE HAVE THAT CONVERSATION I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE DO MOVE
INTO THAT AREA.
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE ARE IN
THE BENCHMARKS THAT WE SET UP
FOR. OUR ARE EFFECTIVE AND SO MY
QUESTION IS DO THESE.
AUDITS HELP YOU.
TO.
DEVELOPED A BUDGET AND SHOULD WE
INCLUDE YOU.
AND THE DISCUSSION OF WHAT THE
PARAMETERS OF OF OF AUDIT SHOULD
BE SAID YOU COULD BETTER.
DO THE BUDGET OR THAT SOMETHING
BOTH FINANCE IN.
HELLO LA OH WANNA STAY AWAY FROM
MORE.
WE WELCOME THE DISCUSSION A
WOULD SAY I WAS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT THAN AN AUDIT THAT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING EXTENSIVELY
WITH I ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB SIX.
ACTUALLY AND WHAT WE CALL OUR
MISSION BASED BUDGETING AND
DEVELOPING CERTAIN DEPARTMENTS
TO LOOK AT AND WHICH WE LOOK AT
EFFICIENCIES AND. REVIEW THE
CORE MISSION OF THE DEPARTMENT
TO YOUR POINT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE BEING
UTILIZED EFFECTIVELY. AND SO WE
WE DO LIKE LOOKING AT
EFFECTIVENESS AND WE WELCOME THE
CONVERSATION.
OKAY AND THEN ANDI DE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE I WOULD LIKE.
AS A FORMER.
.
DIRECTOR WILL STAY FOR THE
CIVILIZED I KNOW WHERE WOEFULLY
BEHIND WHEN IT COMES DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ON ALL GOVERNMENT
BUILDINGS IT'S JUST SOMETHING.
THAT DURING BAD BUDGET TIMES WE
JUST IGNORE AND HOPE THAT THE
BUILDING DOESN'T FALL DOWN
AROUND OUR EARS. AND SO.
I WOULD LIKE TO BE PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION BECAUSE WHAT I FOUND.
IS SOMETIMES FOR NOT VERY GOOD
AT.
DEVELOPING
HOW WE'RE GOING TO TO HANDLE
FIXING ROOFS IN.
KITCHENS YOU KNOW I'VE I SAW ONE
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
FOR LIKE A BUCK TEN MILLION
DOLLAR KITCHEN.
I YOU THINK.
ON TV THEY HAVE KITCHEN DEBT
THAT EXPENSIVE.
BUT.
IT MAY NEED ALL THAT AND I.
WOULD LOVE TO BE INVOLVED. IN
THOSE DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE
SOMETIMES.
DO SOME WAYS TO DO IT BOMB.
I DON'T SEE CHEAPER BECAUSE YOU
DON'T WANT.
IT BENT CHEAPLY YOU WANTED DONE
ALONE MORE EFFICIENTLY AND AND
IN A BETTER USE OF OF THE
DOLLARS.
AND.
AND THAT'S IT FOR NOW.
SO.
IF YOU CAN HELP ME WITH HOW
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
REHABILITATION DOLLARS.
BECAUSE WE PROP FIFTY SEVEN
FORTY SEVEN AND OO.
GET THE MONIES WON'T STOP THEM
THANK GOD FOR ALL OF THESE AND
SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN WORK WITH
YOU. SORT OF IMPROVE THATFOR
EVERY DOLLAR WE SPEND ON
REHABILITATION WE SAVE MONEY WE
NEED TO PUT MORE MONEY INTO IT.
SO CAN ACTUALLY MEET SOME OF
THESE GOALS LIKE CLOSING PRIVATE
PRISONS
THE FOUR THOUSAND HOW THE STATE.
FORTY TWO HUNDRED AND STATE
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED LEAST.
THERE'S A ONE WEEK CLOSE BY
TWENTY TWENTY.
IF WE'RE EFFECTIVE ON A
REHABILITATION PROGRAM WE CAN
CLOSE THAT AND PROBABLY REDUCE
THAT NUMBER DOWN. ON
INCARCERATED SIDE
YEAH IS SIMILAR WE JUST RECENTLY
PUT OUT A REPORT ON REHAB
PROGRAMS. SO WE'D BE VERY HAPPY
TO WORK WITH YOU AND AND THE
THRUST OF IT WAS WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PROGRAMS THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS OPERATING.
SINCE THEY HAVE SOME MORE MONEY
NOW.
ARE THEY EVIDENCE BASED HAVE
THEY BEEN SHOWN TO WORK.
BUT THAT'S JUST A NECESSARY BUT
NOT SUFFICIENT THEY HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE OPERATING
THEM.
IN WAYS THAT ARE SUCCESSFUL YOU
CAN'T JUST SAY YOU'RE RUNNING
THE PROGRAM. BUT THE METRIC
SEVENTH SO WE'D BE VERY HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOU AND I HOPE THAT
REPORT WILL HELP YOU PROVIDE
SOME GUIDANCE FOR YOU TO. AN
ELASTIC ON THAT WHEN I'VE ASKED
FOR EFFECTIVENESS OF ON
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS ALAS.
SO IF SOMEONE STAYS OUT FOR YEAR
DEBTS WE USE TO BE SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND THAT WAS SAFE BY THINGS
UP EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND OR MORE
THAT WE SPEND ON PEOPLE
INCARCERATED. THEY DON'T COME
BACK THAT'S WHAT WE SAVE.
AND WHEN I ASK HOW DO YOU DO YOU
CAN YOU KEEP RECORDS OF THAT AND
SOMEONE WILL TELL ME NO WE
CAN'T.
AND THEY'LL TELL THEM WHAT THEY
PAY THEIR STATE TAXES ARE PRETTY
GOOD.
YOU PRETTY SURE THAT THEY HAVE
NOT. GONE BACK TO A LIFE OF
CRIME.
SO ONCE YOU GO AND CHECK.
WITH THESE
PEOPLE WHO DO OUR STATE AND GET
THAT INFORMATION YOU FIND OUT
WHAT INMATES.
FORMER LEE INCARCERATED ARE NOW
LONG LONGER CAMINO CRAP THAT'S A
SAVINGS TO BATTLING TO TO THE
STATE BUT IS ALSO REVENUE.
TO THE STATE BY THEM PAYING
THEIR TAXES.
AND SOMEONE WILL GO OH.
I KNOW WE COULD DO THAT.
SO DO ALSO SOME REALLY EASY WAYS
WE CAN.
TERMIN HOW EFFECTIVE THESE
PROGRAMS ARE AND HOPEFULLY CAN
YOU CAN WORK WITH ME SO WE CAN
IDENTIFY THAT BE HAPPY TO.
THANK YOU.
MISTER BLOOM.
THANK YOU I DON'T KNOW.
MISTER BLOOM GOING TO SIT. DOWN.
SORRY THROUGH ITS DOUBLE THE.
CONFUSION COMING UP TO TWO MORE
TO MORE DOCTOR WHAT'S OUR.
THANK YOU.
AND.
MS CONSTANT MISTER TAYLOR
SCRIPTED
SEE YOU AGAIN I'M.
BACK FOR MY SIX DUH SUCCESS OF.
BUDGET IF.
IF I'M COUNTY CORRECTLY AND I'M.
GLAD TO TO BE HEARD THE WORKING
WITH YOU AGAIN ITEM I I WANTED
TO REITERATE TO SOME OF THE.
COMMENTS THAT MY COLLEAGUES MADE
ABOUT THE COURT'S EARLIER ON IN
OUR DISCUSSION AND.
I.
AM VERY CONCERNED THAT THE
COURTS COMPARED TO OTHER
DEPARTMENTS IN THE STATE ARE
LAGGING FAR BEHIND. IN
RESTORATION OF FUNDING IF YOU
LOOK AT. EVEN CONSIDERING A LOT
OF THE REFORMS THAT HAVE TAKEN
PLACE IN THE.
MEANTIME BUT IF YOU LOOK BACK
AT THE BASELINE FUNDING THAT
EXISTED.
AT THE TIME THE RECESSION HIT
THE CONDITION OF THE COURTS WERE
AND WHICH WAS GREAT THEN.
COMPARED TOHOW WE'VE RESTORED
MONEY AND I'M GRATEFUL THAT
THERE IS MORE MONEY THIS YEAR IN
THE BUDGET THAN PAST YEARS. BUT
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
ASSESS
HOW FAR ALONG WE ARE IN
RESTORING THE COURTS TO WHERE
THEY SHOULD BE. AUTUMN AND I'M.
WONDERING IF I.
YOUR DEPARTMENT CAN SHED TO
EITHER YOU CAN SHED LIGHT ON
THAT.
AND THEN THAT ARE ALSO ON THE
COURTS WHEN IT COMES TO
INFRASTRUCTURE I WAS STRUCK BY
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SALINAS ABOUT A COURT THAT
SHE KNOWS IN THAT I'VE HEARD
ABOUT IS A MEMBER OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. ACCORD THAT.
NEEDS WORK AND ISN'T EVEN ON
THE LIST OF SEVENTEEN COURTS
THAT IS SLATED FOR FUNDING OVER.
APPARENTLY SOUNDS LIKE OVER THE
NEXT TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OR SO.
AND SO THAT CONCERNS ME BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT A LOT OF OUR.
COURTS
HAVE BEEN STRAPPED FOR A.
I CASH THAT THEY NEED TO DO
ROUTINE MAINTENANCE AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE.
AND AND TO IN MANY CASES THE
COURTS ARE LITERALLY HELD
TOGETHER BY BAILING WIRE AND AND
THAT DUCT TAPE TO EVER.
ISN'T ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IN OUR
COURT SYSTEM SOMEONE OR IF YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
THINK ANY MAJOR ARRESTS AND
WHATSOEVER TO FINANCE A THINK
AND JUST AS THE COMPARISON POINT
AGREE THAT WERE NOT AT THE LEVEL
THAT WE'RE FULLY REFUNDED OUT IN
PRIOR YEARS I'M. GOING BACK TO
SEVEN EIGHT WE WERE OUR TRIAL
COURTS REFUNDED ABOUT AND THREE
POINT THREE MILLION AND WERE NOW
I'M JUST UNDER THREE MILLION IN
OUR PROPOSED BUDGET. I AM I
DON'T KNOW THAT WERE NECESSARILY
TRYING TO GET BACK TO A CERTAIN
LEVEL BUT TRYING TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS BASED ON THE
WORKLOAD IN CASE THAT THAT'S
BEFORE THE COURTS AND NOW. I AM
GOING TO START WITH GILLIAN.
ASSUME THAT WAS A SLIGHT MISTAKE
I APOLOGIZE I ASSUME THE
WORKLOAD IS ONLY INCURS.
THAT BE CORRECT.
I THINK SO I MEAN THERE HAS
DEFINITELY BEEN CHANGES BETWEEN
AND THEY DON'T HAVE ANY IN THE
DATA WITH IN FRONT OF ME
BETWEEN.
AND I CRIMINAL CASE FILENE'S ON
CIVIL CASE EILEEN'S I'M ALL OF
THOSE THINGS CERTAINLY HAVE
CHANGED OVER TIME AND THAT IT'S
SOME DEPEND ON THE AVAILABILITY
AND ACCESS TO COURT SERVICES.
AND THERE'S A LOT MORE SELF
REPRESENTED LIBERTY LITIGANTS IN
THE COURT SYSTEM NOW WHICH WE'VE
MADE A LOT OF INVESTMENTS IN
THAT AREA TO TRY TO HELP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. THAT OTHERWISE
WOULD BE ABLE TO GET.
ACCESS TO THE COURTS
SO RECOGNIZING THAT WERE WERE
TRYING TO MAKE STRIDES IN THIS
AREA BUT. AREN'T NECESSARILY.
AIMING TO GET BACK TO A CERTAIN
FUNDING LEVEL I WANT TO COMMEND
YOU ON A PROVIDING MORE FUNDING
FOR SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS
IT IS AN ENORMOUS PROBLEM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BUT.
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
PROVIDING THAT HELP IS ONLY ONE
PIECE OF THE.
OF OF THE OF THE PUZZLE IF A
SELF REPRESENTED LITIGANTS.
CAN'T GET A COURT DATE AND HAS
TO COME BACK NUMEROUS TIMES IN
ORDER TO HAVE. A IS A HER ISSUE
RESOLVED.
WE'RE NOT DOING A THEM A
PARTICULARLY.
A SELFLESS REPRESENT LITIGANTS
ARE TYPICALLY PORT THAT'S WHY
THEIR SELF REPRESENTED.
THEIR LOSING TIME FROM WORK OUT
OF THEIR SCHEDULES THEY'RE
HAVING TO TRAVEL.
LONGER DISTANCES THAN THEY DID
IN THE PAST BECAUSE WE CLOSE SO
MANY COURTHOUSES AND SO I I DO
THINK THAT WE OUGHT TO BE.
ASSESSING.
WHAT OUR PLAN IS FOR RESTORING
THE COURTS TO THE PLACE THAT
THEY NEED TO BE NOW THE? COURTS
HAVE DONE THAT OF SO THE
QUESTION IS WHAT WE ARE DOING.
AS A LEGISLATURE AND IN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BRANCH TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES
I JUST.
LEAVE YOU WITH WITHOUT THAT I
THINK VERY IMPORTANT.
COMMENTS ON THE SECOND QUESTION
I WANTED TO ASK AND.
I SUPPOSE IT'S A IN THE IN THE
NATURE OF A BOTH A COMMENT AND A
AND A QUESTION. OF HAS TO DO
WITH THE EARLIER DISCUSSION
ABOUT.
THE.
A RAINY DAY FUND AND AND AND
AND THE RESERVE. AND I THINK
THAT.
FOR FOR MOST MEMBERS WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A GOOD
THING THAT WE'RE DOING IN A
NECESSARY THING TO PROTECT
AGAINST.
ABOUT WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN NEXT BUT
WHAT. IS LEFT AND SAID HERE.
WHICH TOUCHED ON IS THE
VOLATILITY OF OUR REVENUE
STREAMS AND WHAT IS LEFT UNSAID
IS WHAT WE CAN DO TO ADDRESS
THAT VOLATILITY. IN THE FORM OF
TAX REFORM.
OUR OUR OUR REVENUE STREAMS ARE
VOLATILE IN PART.
BECAUSE WE RELY ON AN ANTIQUATED
SYSTEM THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
APPROVE OF OF REVENUE GENERATION
THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN APPROPRIATE
GENERATIONS AGO BUT WE'VE DONE
NOTHING TO TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION.
AND.
I'M WONDERING WHETHER THE
ADMINISTRATION INTENDS TO
ADDRESS THAT IN THIS BUDGET OR
PERHAPS IN THE GOVERNOR'S STATED
THE STATE. OF THURSDAY'S GOT ONE
MORE OPPORTUNITY IT IS MY
OPINION THAT I THINK. MANY HAVE
A SEAT NEED FOR THAT KIND OF
REFORM BUT THAT IT IS GOING TO
TAKE LEADERSHIP FROM THE. TOP TO
REALLY MAKE IT HAPPEN.
THANK YOU OBVIOUSLY AS I SAID
THE FEDERAL TAX REFORM HAPPENED
TO HAVE WHEN WE ARE PAST OR
INTERNAL PUBLICATION DEADLINE
HOWEVER CERTAINLY THERE'S
SEVERAL DIFFERENT A LEGISLATIVE
MEASURES MOVING THROUGH RIGHT
NOW. TO DEAL WITH SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT YOU'VE OUTLINED THAT
BECAME MORE PRONOUNCED CANDIDLY
AFTER THE FEDERAL TAX REFORM SO
WE'RE BEGINNING TO LOOK INTO
EACH OF THOSE LEGISLATIVE
MEASURES AND I'M HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
CARRYING THOSE BILLS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI THAN DUCT
WORK.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR WAITING.
NOW HUNGRY TIME ON MOST OF A
CLOCK.
I FOR ONE ON MY QUESTIONS.
I'M IN A NEW AREA IN GENERAL.
THIS IS MY SECOND YEAR.
DEALING WITH THESE ARTISTS
BUDGET.
IS SUDDENLY YA VERY.
GOOD THEN THE POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE SAID THAT WE DO WE
HAVE A SURPLUS BUDGET. RATHER
THAN DEFICIT.
WHICH IS GOOD THE HOWEVER I'M
WONDERING ALL THIS SOCCER.
A BUDGET EXPENDITURE PROPOSED
OR SOUGHT AFTER WE SEE AND THEN
ALSO A LOT OF QUESTIONS HAVE
BEEN RAISED TO.
WHEN THE GOVERNOR US.
A FACE ESOS O. SUCH A HUGE.
A SEPARATE US SO I WONDER
WHETHER IT IS SEE THE ONE NO.
BY HIMSELF LA SETTING THE PRES
BOROUGH HALL TO SUPPRESS WOULD
BE HANDLED OR.
A. DEAL I HAVE FOUR OR OR.
YOU OFF HIS.
MAKES SUGGESTIONS.
.
THE THOUGHT DOESN'T JUST MAIS
GENERAL CURIOSITY HOW.
WHAT WHETHER THERE'S ANY ANY
PRINCIPLE BECAUSE OUR?
I AS YOU KNOW IF YOU IF YOU'RE
GONNA SPEND THAT MONEY YOU CAN
SPEND THAT ANYWHERE.
BUT THE MY THINKING IS THAT
TERM.
AND SINCE WE HAVE.
ASSIST YOU IT I THINK THAT
THREE WAY SO MAYBE WE CAN THINK
WAY IS SO OBVIOUSLY.
.
A DID YOU SAY THAT THE FOUR
FIFTHS OF PR SURPLUS HAVE BEEN
US.
PUT INTO RAINY DAY OF RESERVES.
SO WHICH IS SOMEONE ONE WAY. AT
THE OTHER ONE AND IS.
.
AND TO.
PAYOFF FOR. BUT THAT DEBTS.
THAT THE WE WE HAVE A SISTER SO.
PUBLIC OPINION OUR LIABILITY
YEAR LIKE APPROVES. A PENSION
LIABILITIES SO HUGE WHAT THE
TWENTY SEVEN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS SO INSIDE OF ME.
A THAT'S DOWN A BECAUSE AT THAT
OBVIOUSLY WOULD YOU CUT DOWN THE
IN INTEREST COSTA.
AND THEN ALSO THE OTHER
FACILITIES. I WAS NOT QUITE SURE
WHEN ARE YOU.
AND PSEUDO QUESTIONS. OUT
REGARDING THE.
PRISON FACILITIES SO. SINCE I
HERE HARM PROFIT.
PRISONS SO. ANA CONTRACTED
DOWNFALL WHERE INMATES ARE. SO
THAT IN CASE OF THAT DOWN WE ARE
IN SHORT OF OUR.
PRISON FACILITIES.
THERE IS SO SURPLUS IS SO WE'VE
KNOWN WITH THIS ARE. OUT COULD
BE ONE TIME WHILE COULD BE
ONGOING BUT IS SO SO HERE WE
CANNOT. DENY THAT NGUYEN
INDEFINITELY CONTINUE. BUT THE
CONSTRUCTION CAN BE ONE TIME NON
FACILITY AND THE. THOUGHT IT CAN
BE DONE AND AIR HALL HOW MANY
ROOMS CAMBIA.
BUILT TO WITH THE. AVAILABLE
FUNDS OF BUT THE ADRIATIC CAN BE
A GOOD. USE UP A ONE TIME FUN.
SO. IN PRINCIPLE.
WHERE AND A HALL WITH THE
SURPLUS IS WOULD BE USED SELF
RATHER THAN LISTENING TO ALL
DIFFERENT ARE?
A DEPARTMENTS SO HEY WE NEED
THIS MONEY DISAPPEAR NUYS SO.
BUT I THINK THERE HAS TO BE
SOME.
BASIC A PHILOSOPHY HOW TO
APPROACH. IN DEALING WITH A SUCH
AS ALONG SUPPRESSES BUT.
I'M NOT GOING BACK MY FIRST
QUESTION. OF HOW DOES HE DECIDE
IN DEALING WITH A SURPLUS
EXPENDITURES.
THANK YOU SO I HAD DURING THE
HOLIDAYS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SPENDS A LOT OF TIME
WITH THE GOVERNOR DEVELOPING THE
BUDGET BASED ON THE REVENUES IN
THE FORECAST THAT WE HAVE IN
MIND.
I WOULD NOTE THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF THE BUDGET SEASON
WE'VE OBVIOUSLY GIVING YOUR OUR
BUDGET PROPOSAL YOUR SUB
COMMITTEES WILL MEET AND CONFER
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT YOU AGREE
WITH OUR PRINCIPLES AS WE.
MOVE TOWARDS THE CONSTITUTIONAL
DEADLINE OF PASSING THE BUDGET
ON JUNE FIFTEENTH.
I THINK FUNDAMENTALLY THE
ARCHITECTURE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET IS BASED ON.
IT'S NOT JUST THE SURPLUS YOU TO
LOOK AT THE NATURE OF THE
SURPLUS AND MUCH DRIVING IT EONS
ON TO THE ANALYST EARLIER
POINTS.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A POINT IN
TIME WHEN WE HAVE TO PUT THE
BUDGET TOGETHER TO ACTUALLY
LITERALLY SEND IT TO THE
PRINTING PRESS AND WE'RE STILL
GATHERING MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE NATURE OF REVENUES AND WHILE
THEY'RE COMING AND HIGHER BUT WE
KNOW A LOT OF ITS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE. PERSONAL INCOME TAX
AND CAP GAINS.
THEREFORE YOU HAVE TO WONDER IF
ITS ONGOING SURPLUS OR FITS ONE
TIME IN NATURE AND IN OUR
ESTIMATION WE ARE PUTTING
TOGETHER THIS DOCUMENT WAS
REALLY ONE TIME THE NATURE. AND
SO THAT'S WHY OUR PRINCIPLES ARE
REALLY.
.
PRUDENT IN BUILDING UP THE
RESERVE IS WELL AS LIMITING MANY
OF OUR EXPENDITURES TO THOSE
THAT ARE ONE TIME IN NATURE.
BECAUSE OF.
.
IS SURPLUS IS OBVIOUSLY
ENOUGH FOR REVENUE.
YOUR PAST RECORD THAT. I SEE IS
THAT.
.
NOT GENERAL FUND SPENDING HAS
GROWN. AT THE NEARLY THREE TIMES
THE RATE OF INFLATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
SOURCE SINCE WE HAVE MONEY LESS
SPENDING SO I THINK.
IF DIAZ STATE BUDGET. HAS GROWN
AT THE RATE OF ONLY INFLATION.
THE.
BUDGET ORDER BEEN.
SELECTED OVER ONE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IS UP ARE. A
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS
THAT'S RIGHT THERE WE COULD HAVE
A SAFE THE THIRTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS.
SO WHY DOES IT HAVE TO BE
EXPERTS EIGHT EXPENDITURE AWAY
OR FOR AWHILE.
INFLATION RATE.
I THINK WHEN THE ANALYST
DEVELOPS THE ONE PAGER ON BUDGET
FORMULAS THAT WILL ILLUMINATE
SOME OF THAT AS SOME OF THIS IS
CASELOAD DRIVEN.
I THOUGHT OF IT IS THAT OUR
PROGRAMS OUR CASELOAD DRIVE AND
I AND THE OTHER THING IS THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE OBVIOUSLY AND IT
DRIVES OFF OF. A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT FACTORS INCLUDING OUR
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE AND
YEAR OVER YEAR GROWTH IN
REVENUES. SO.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF FACTORS
THAT AND HAPPEN ON THE NATURAL
AS REVENUES COME IN. AND I THINK
THAT ONE PAGE WILL PROVIDE YOU
SOME ADDITIONAL DETAIL ON SOME
OF THOSE THINGS THAT AND
HAPPENED REALLY ON THE NATURAL.
COMMENTS.
SURE I THINK AS MISS COSTA SAID
YOU.
YOU TYPICALLY WILL HAVE TO
INCREASE EXPENDITURES FOR
INFLATION THEIR PROP NINETY
EIGHT FORMULA HAS THAT SORT OF
IMPLICITLY BUILT IN ALONG WITH
ENROLLMENT GROWTH. THE
LEGISLATURE'S ALSO MADE YOU KNOW
ITS OWN DECISIONS ABOUT
ADDITIONAL THINGS THAT ONE.
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES.
.
AFFECTED THE STATE. I DECISIONS
TO ADD ADDITIONAL SERVICES OR
ADDITIONAL HOURS IN.
AYE H. ASSESS.
ADDED MOMENT GROWTH IN YOU SEE
I MEAN THESE ARE JUST DECISIONS
THE LEGISLATURE MAKES EVERY
YEAR.
AND IT TENDS TO HAVE SPENDING
GROW T AT GREATER THAT
INFLATION.
JUST LOOKING AT THE.
THIS IS RELATES TO REALLY MISTER
OBERNOLTE QUESTION.
THE LAST THREE YEARS IT LOOKS
LIKE GENERAL FUND SPENDING GREW
AT ABOUT ONE PERCENT FOUR
PERCENT.
SIX POINT TWO PERCENT AND SELL
PROPOSED FOR FOUR POINT ONE
PERCENT.
THOSE ARE ROUGHLY IN LINE WITH
YOUR REVENUE GROWTH.
SO IT'S JUST YOUR DECISIONS THAT
YOU MAKE ABOUT HOW YOU ALLOCATE
THAT MONEY.
GOVERNOR US OUT A PROPOSED A
BUDGET THAT INCLUDES SELF.
FOUR HUNDRED.
NEW POLLUTION SAW OUT WITH THE
CALTRANS ISSUE WE ARE.
HAVE A HEART ABOUT THE.
THE COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE
INEFFICIENT THE OPERATIONAL
CALTRANS.
NOW IS SO.
INEFFICIENCIES OR BECAUSE OF
THE PIPE AND YOU EMPLOYEES
ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED PEOPLE
RATHER THAN STREAMLINING WHILE
FINDING SOME. BETTER WAYS OF
IMPROVING THE SERVICE SO. THAT
THAT THIS HAS SOUGHT JUST
THOUGHT ADDING ONE TOP OFFER IN.
ARE.
INEFFICIENT OPERATIONS.
I WOULD NOTE TWO POINTS.
ONE WERE PROPOSING A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN SP ONE OF SEVEN
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS NOT
SIMPLY REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE.
AS MY COLLEAGUE MISTER WELLS
MENTIONED ALSO WE RECENTLY
APPOINTED AN INSPECTOR GENERAL
ONTO CALTRANS TO OVERVIEW THESE
PROJECT DOLLARS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE BEING SPENT EFFICIENTLY
AND EFFECTIVELY.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
IS WHEN YOU SPENDING SEVEN POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IT DOES
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL. ON EMPLOYEES
EMPLOYEES THAT WE WOULD UTILIZE
THROUGH THE BOND FUNDS VERSUS
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS. ON AND SO
THAT'S OUR. OUR INCREASE STAFF
LOAD IS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PROJECTS WE THINK WILL BE FUNDED
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. IS THAT THE
FOUR HUNDRED NEW EMPLOYEES A
SUCH A PROPOSED THAT BECAUSE
SUFFER SP ONE PASSED A
IMPLEMENTATION.
THAT'S CORRECT.
YOU NEED THE GOVERNMENT TO.
BUT ASSEMBLYMAN WE'VE OBVIOUSLY
RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT CALTRANS
STAFFING LEVELS IN THE PAST.
SO WE'LL BE TAKING A LOOK AT IT
IT'S NO QUESTION THAT THEIR WORK
LOAD WILL INCREASE.
THE QUESTION WAS DID THEY HAVE
THE PEOPLE ALREADY THAT.
COULD HANDLE THIS WORKLOAD SO
WE'LL DEFINITELY TAKING A LOOK
AT THAT.
OKAY IF YOU'RE THERE ARE.
FINAL IS JUST AS I I I DON'T
THINK WE CAN.
THE FIND ANY SOLUTIONS HERE.
I COME FROM US HERE FOR IRVINE
AND.
DOES TOOL TO HELP WHICH IS YOU
CAN.
YOU YOU CAN GO BY NUMBER ONE IS
SO INCREASING YOUR OWN STAFF OR
CONTRACTING OUT. MANY SERVICES
ARE DOWN FROM MY STUDIO
EXPERIENCE US CONTRACTING OUT
THIS SAVED US A LOT OF OUR
MONEY.
HAVE HAVE YOU ARE THE HAVE THE
CATCHER AND THOUGHT ABOUT THEM
OF CERTAIN PORTIONS A WORKER CAN
BE CONTRACTED OUT THERE BY THE
TEN INCREASING THE IN ALL TO
EMPLOYEES A SIZE OF THE
CALTRANS.
STATUE ACTUALLY SPECIFIES HOW
MANY CONTRACT EMPLOYEES WE CAN
UTILIZE ACCOUNT UP CALTRANS.
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI.
DOCTOR WHAT.
ABOUT
COUPLE HOPEFULLY QUICK THINGS
FOR YOU SO.
WITH THE.
PASSAGE OF.
CONTINUE RESOLUTION IN CONGRESS
THAT FUNDS CHIP.
WHAT IS THE BUDGET AND WHAT IS
THE ROUGH AND I DON'T I SHOULD
HAVE BEEN FROM A FIGHT PROJECTS
THAT DON'T WOOD IS ONE OF THE
ROUGH BUDGET IMPLICATIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA? OBVIOUSLY THE
POSITIVE SO.
.
HOW DID YOU GET IT WOULD BE A
WITH WHAT IS THE NUMBER THAT
WILL BE?
ABOUT.
I'M ALL ALONE MY STAFF BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS LATE BREAKING
NEWS BUT ALREADY WHEN WE PASSED
AT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR PUBLICATION WE KNEW
THAT WE WOULD BE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION TO THE GOOD BASED
ON HOW WE HAD BUILT IN OUR
ASSUMPTIONS.
I'M OBVIOUSLY AND THIS LINKED OF
AN EXTENSION IS GREAT NEWS FOR
US AND WE JUST STARTED REVIEWING
THE BILL SO WE HAVE SOME ROUGH
NUMBERS ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS ON
HIM
TO HEAR.
YEAH UNDERSEA DEPARTMENT BY IT
SO.
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE ONE QUARTER THAT THEY
DID ON THE SHORT TERM BASIS AND
SO OUT WE ALREADY KNEW WHEN WE
RELEASED THE BUDGET WE'RE GOING
TO BUILD THAT INTO MAY. AND
FRANKLY THE RATES AND THE
POPULATION IN THAT PROGRAMISN'T
CHANGING SO DRAMATICALLY THAT I
DON'T THINK THAT I THINK THAT
ONE FIFTY PER QUARTER IS A
PRETTY GOOD RULE OF THUMB SO. IN
OTHER WORDS IF WE'RE GONNA GET
EIGHTY EIGHT PERCENT FEDERAL
SHARE I'M IN THE BUDGET YEARS
WELL YOU COULD PROBABLY MULTIPLY
THAT NUMBER BY FOUR GET ROUGH
SETS.
AND AND THIS IS MORE COMMENTARY
I GUESS.
THE.
A VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET.
GRANTS THAT CALIFORNIA WILL BE
ADMINISTERING TO HELP WITH.
SOME OF THE FORCE IF YOUR FUEL
FORCE CHALLENGES WE HAVE.
CONCERNED THAT ACTUALLY THAT
NUMBER MAY BE LOW.
FROM WHAT WE WHAT WE ACTUALLY
NEED BUT ALSO CONCERNED THAT THE
GRANT PROCESS MIGHT BE ONEROUS
AND DIFFICULT AND SLOW.
AND.
NOT NOT TO IT AS AS IT IS WITH
A LOT OF AGENCIES ARE NOT JUST
PICKING ON CALPERS ON MY CALVET
THIS POINT BUT. BUT IS THERE ARE
GOING TO BE AN EMPHASIS HELP
EXPEDITE THAT PROCESS THE PEOPLE
WE CAN ACTUALLY SPEND THIS
RESOURCES TO ACTUALLY PROTECT.
LIVES AND PROPERTY AND AND OUR
FORESTS OR WILL THIS BE.
MORE OF A TYPICAL PROCESS.
WE ACTUALLY HAD AN EXEMPTION FOR
ALL PROGRAMS FUNDED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR ADDED GIGI ARE AT
FROM THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT ONTO YOUR POINT
TO KIND OF ACTS BUT AT SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS GOING OUT SO I'M
AND CERTAINLY THE CAL FIRE
PROJECT IS ONE THAT WOULD APPLY.
FOR THAT EXEMPTION.
AND JUST YOU KNOW IT WEIRD AS
YOUR TALK ABOUT METRICS EARLIER
AND AND CONCERNS.
I REPRESENT THE AREA THAT HAVE
THE TUBS FIRE.
WHICH UNTIL THOMAS FIRE WAS THE
THE MOST EXPENSIVE FIRE IN THE
STATE.
AND AND I THINK ONE OF THE.
THE CONCERNS THAT THAT I'VE HAD
IN AWHILE WHILE THIS FIRE WAS
UNIQUE I IN THAT THEY ALL ARE
BUT.
WE LOST A LOT OF FORCE LAND WE
ALSO IS IS DIFFERENT AND SOME OF
THE OTHER FIRES THAT WE'VE HAD
IN THE SIERRAS.
WE'RE HOPING I'M HOPING AT SOME
POINT.
THAT THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
PROVIDE SYMMETRIX SO WE
UNDERSTAND THE.
THEIMPLICATIONS OF TO
GREENHOUSE GASES WHEN THESE
LARGE FIRES ERUPT I MEAN
ANECDOTALLY WE'VE HEARD THAT.
WHEN THESE LARGE FIRES.
EXCEEDS OR EQUALS.
THE ENTIRE.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS FOR A SINGLE
YEAR AND WE HAD. MULTIPLE EVENTS
THIS YEAR AND SO THAT BRINGS MY
QUESTION IS ARE WE.
ARE WE GETTING OUR BANG FOR OUR
BUCK HERE ARE QUITE FRANKLY I
EXPERIENCED IN MY DISTRICT THE
WORST AIR QUALITY EVER RECORDED.
EVER RECORDED YET.
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
ALLOCATIONS FROM THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES OF
WHICH I REPRESENT A LOT.
WE DON'T GET THE RESOURCES
BECAUSE OF THE.
AND VIRUS SCAN AND THE WAY
THINGS ARE CALCULATED.
SO.
I WAS LOOKING FOR RECOGNITION
THAT. WOW THERE'S A THIS AIR
QUALITY IS REALLY BAD AND THERE
SHOULD BE RESOURCES HERE AND
THAT THERE'S A RECOGNITION THAT
THIS ACTUALLY IS A CONTRIBUTOR
TO GREENHOUSE GASES.
AND WHAT THAT NUMBER REALLY AS
BECAUSE.
I'D YOU KNOW I'D I JUST WORRY
THAT THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE BUT THE
PROCESS THAT MAKE UP THERE. BUT
I JUST FEAR THAT IS REALLY
REALLY NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH.
SO A MAN ONLY DEPARTMENT FINANCE
AGAIN.
A PART OF THE KAPPA DRITTE
EXPENDITURE.
STRUCTURE IS THAT.
EVERY YEAR THE ADMINISTRATION
RELEASES AN ANNUAL REPORT TO
PROVIDE.
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
INTO THE PUBLIC IN TERMS OF THE
OUTCOMES
THAT HAS.
RESULTED AS A RESULT OF THE
EXPENDITURES OF CAPITATE FUNDS
IN WITHIN THAT IS A ESTIMATION
OF GHG EMISSION REDUCTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROJECTS
THAT ARE FUNDED.
IF YOU LOOK HISTORICALLY AT THE
HEALTHY FOREST PROGRAM THAT'S
ADMINISTERED BY.
CAL FIRE. THAT IS ONE OF THE
MORE COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS NOT
ONLY BECAUSE.
OF WHAT YOU WERE ALLUDING TO
WHICH IS THE.
.
AVOIDANCE OF.
OF.
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATE WITH FIRES
BUT THE CARBON SEQUESTRATION
BENEFITS
OF.
OF TREES
SO IT'S KIND OF A WIN WIN ON
MULTIPLE LEVELS THAT.
.
YOU NO REDUCES RISK IN TERMS OF
PUBLIC SAFETY IT REDUCES
EMISSIONS IS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE.
.
WITH WILDFIRES AS WELL AS THE.
HAS CARBON SINK BENEFIT SO.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY.
WE HAD SUCH A MAJOR INVESTMENT
IN THE HEALTHY FORCE PROGRAM WAS
A FOR THAT VERY REASON YOU
ALLUDED TO.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND AND HOPE
ON ONGOING BASIS THAT WE CAN.
MORE OF THAT I YOU KNOW IT WE
HEAR THAT STUFF I'VE HEARD FROM.
DEBT THAT PEOPLE IN CARD SOME
OF THEM ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT
THESE FORCE FIRES OR ACTS OF
GOD.
I WOULD DISAGREE I THINK THAT WE
HAVE MADE SOME OF THE SITUATIONS
WORSE UP BY OUR INABILITY TO
MANAGE FORESTS. AND.
AND SO SO I'M JUST LOOKING I'M
A NUMBERS PERSON I WANT TO SEE
THE NUMBERS I WANT TO UNDERSTAND
HOW MUCH CARBON CAN BE
SEQUESTERED WHEN WE ACTUALLY DO
THESE PROJECTS. ALSO
UNDERESTIMATE HOW MUCH CARBON WE
BLOW OFF WHEN WE HAVE THESE BIG
FIRES I WANT TO SEE THOSE
COMPARISONS BECAUSE I THINK WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY SPENDING.
THE RESOURCES TO MINIMIZE THE
AMOUNT OF GREENHOUSE GASES KNOWN
THAT BUT ALSO TO MINIMIZE THE
EFFECTS OF OF AIR POLLUTION AND
IF YOU'D SPENT. THREE OR FOUR
WEEKS IN MY DISTRICT YOU GET IT.
PEOPLE WANDERING AROUND WITH
MASKS ON.
FOR FOUR WEEKS ON FOR WEEKS
BECAUSE OF THE POOR AIR QUALITY.
AND AND.
I SWEAR RECOGNITION THAT THIS IS
AN ISSUE.
FROM THAT AGENCY.
AND APPRECIATES COME FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BUT I'M NOT
HEARING THAT FROM THAT AGENCY.
AND I'D LIKE I'D LIKE A
RECOGNITION OF THAT.
THANK YOU DON'T WORK. UP MR
SWITCHING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR UP MS
COST I.
.
INTENDED TO BRING THIS UP
EARLIER BUT GOING BACK TO THE
ISSUE OF. K. THROUGH TWELVE OF
FUNDING.
THAT YOU YOU YOU.
.
STATED THAT.
YOU KNOW THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
ARE BEING ASKED TO.
EXERCISE THERE GREATER
FLEXIBILITY IN GREATER LOCAL
CONTROL TO.
TO MEET THEIR FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES BUT AGAIN  YOU
KNOW I REPRESENT.
.
DISTRICTS FROM LAUSD THE LARGEST
URBAN SCHOOL DISTRICT IN ONE OF
THE.
BIGGEST RECIPIENTS OF
CONCENTRATION A SUPPLEMENTAL
GRANT DOLLARS AS WELL AS
SUBURBAN DISTRICTS THAT RECEIVE.
LESS OF THOSE.
SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
DOLLARS BUT THEY'RE BOTH SAYING
THAT THE BASS GRANT IS
INADEQUATE TO MEET THEIR BASE.
THEIR BASIC COSTS.
.
AND SO I LIKE TO ASK YOU ABOUT
WHAT THE GOVERNMENT'S POSITION
OUR GOAL UP UNTIL THIS POINT
STUDENT BEN TO FULLY FUND THE
FORMULA WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING IN.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND
AND WE HAVE HEARD. DISTRICTS
TALK ABOUT THE BASS GRANT
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO THEIR
STIRS COST.
A AND WE HAVEN'T OPINES BEYOND
GETTING TO THE HUNDRED PERCENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF LCF.
OKAY IMAC. I'M WORKING WITH. THE
EDUCATION STAKEHOLDERS TO.
TO FOCUS ON THAT ISSUE OF THE
INADEQUACY OF THE BASS GRANT.
AND SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE BECAUSE A A A AGAIN.
DO NO DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE URBAN AS WELL AS SUBURBAN
ROLE THERE ALL SAYING THAT THE
BASS GRANT IS INADEQUATE TO MEET
THEIR BASIC COSTS.
AND.
YOU KNOW IN THESE BUT A GOOD
BUDGET TIMES THEY'RE THEY'RE
PROJECTING MANY ARE PROJECTING
QUALIFIED BUDGETS.
A TWO THREE YEARS OUT AND SO
THAT WAS LAST YEAR I I DON'T
KNOW HOW THE FULL FUNDING OF THE
PROPOSED FULL FUNDING OF LCF F..
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH DATA MAY MAKE
A DIFFERENCE BUT.
.
THE AYE AYE AYE AYE I'M HOPING
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS HERE
LARA CLEAR AND I KNOW THAT I'VE
I'VE HAD OPPORTUNITIES TO.
SPEAK WITH THE.
MEMBERS IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON ON THIS IS.
I.
I JUST WANTED TO.
EMPHASIZE THAT THAT ISSUE AS AN
ONGOING ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. UP AGAIN THIS IS THE
FIRST OF WHAT WILL BE NUMEROUS
HEARINGS YES THERE WILL BE MORE
HEARINGS MORE HEARINGS. LAST
YEAR WE DID A SMALL NUMBER
HEARINGS NINETY EIGHT TO BE
EXACT
SO UNDER A HUNDRED.
AND WE WILL BE VERY EXCITED TO
GO THROUGH EACH AND EVERY PIECE
OF THIS BUDGET AND SUBCOMMITTEE.
MISTER BILL MURRAY HAS MANY
MARCHING ORDERS AND
TRANSPORTATION SO IT'S GOOD.
THAT WILL BE LOOKING GUY VERY
MUCH FORWARD TO THIS AYE PROCESS
AS WE DO EVERY YEAR AND.
.
WE ARE A LOT I'M I'M JUST VERY
FOR CHICAGO OF DISSEMINATED THE
COMMITTEES.
SO ARE WE WILL ON.
RECONVENED IN THE NEXT.
FEW MONTHS BUT WILL BE
OBVIOUSLY GOING THROUGH A VERY
DELIBERATE PROCESS AND THANK
YOU.
ON THIS COSTA MISTER TAYLOR FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY.
WITH THAT WE ARE ADJOURNED